pull up on Tempe Federica Bianco David
grinspoon Carlin toner Josh sametta and
Jennifer Buss one in the front row we
have Walter Scott Warren Randolph Reggie
Brothers Shelley Wright
Scott Kelly
Anna Maria
Mike gold and David spurgle who serves
as chair of the team
I have a few opening remarks but to
begin I'd like to start with the
following
first I'd like to pay tribute to the
life of retired Air Force Master
Sergeant Sam Sato who's being laid to
rest at Arlington National Cemetery
today
following his active duty service Sam
served as the intelligence collection
manager for the National Intelligence
manager for Aviation where he played a
critical role in UAP analysis all of us
at Nasa offer our condolences to Sam's
family friends and colleagues
second I'd like to take this opportunity
to express my profound gratitude to our
distinguished panel of experts for their
unwavering commitment and dedication
it's disheartening to note that several
of them have been subjected to online
abuse due to their decision to
participate on this panel a NASA
security team is actively addressing
this issue we at Nasa are acutely aware
of the considerable public interest in
UAP however it's critical to understand
any form of harassment towards our
panelists only serves to detract from
the scientific process which requires an
environment of respect and openness
now every member of our team is a
recognized Authority in their respective
field and they have our unequivocal
support
NASA stands in solidarity with them
advocating for a respectful discourse
that befits their expertise and the
significance of their work thanks
now in recent years the subject of
unidentified aerial phenomena nowadays
termed unidentified anomalous phenomena
or uaps has captured the attention of
the public the scientific community and
the government alike and it's now our
Collective responsibility to investigate
these incurrences with a rigorous
scientific scrutiny that they deserve
NASA administrator sent us a Bill Nelson
believes that understanding uaps is
vital for several reasons which is why
he directed this study
first and foremost it provides an
opportunity for us to expand our
understanding of the world around us
is an organization dedicated to
exploring the unknown this work is in
our DNA
secondly this study aims to enhance
situational awareness the presence of
uaps raises concerns about the safety of
our skies and it's this nation's
obligation to determine whether these
phenomena pose any potential risks to
airspace safety
by understanding the nature of uaps we
can ensure that our skies remain a safe
space for all
in order to achieve these goals it is
crucial that we employ a scientific lens
for our UAP work it's precisely this
rigorous evidence-based approach that
allows one to separate fact from fiction
this team is comprised of experts from
various disciplines which allows them to
approach this work from multiple
perspective
and we have greatly benefited from that
Collective expertise
now why do we value a scientific
approach it's because science is built
on evidence it thrives on scrutiny it
demands
reproducibility Reaper sorry an above
all objectivity when we approach uaps
from a scientific perspective we do not
come in with an agenda we come in
needing a roadmap indeed the primary
objective of this incredible team of
experts is not to go back and look at
grainy footage of uaps but rather to
give us a roadmap to guide us for future
analysis and this is the very scientific
method that NASA holds true to its heart
scientific research is intended to be
publicly available and transparent a
NASA Prides itself on making its data
and images available to the public to
learn and explore on their own by
holding public meetings like this one we
aim for open and honest dialogue with
the public we recognize that public
interest in uaps is high and that the
demand for answers is strong
conversations like this one are the
first step to reducing the stigma
surrounding UAP reporting
moreover transparency is essential for
fostering trust between NASA the public
and the scientific community
in order to do things right we must work
together pulling our resources our
knowledge and our expertise and by
maintaining open channels of
communication we can facilitate
collaboration encourage the exchange of
ideas and ensure that our work is as
robust as possible
not only that
commitment to openness is in itself a
reflection of NASA's commitment to
Scientific integrity
there's an organization dedicated to the
pursuit of knowledge it is NASA's
responsibility to be honest and
forthright and to follow the science
and by being transparent in our work we
uphold our dedication to Scientific
excellence
the meeting today represents the first
deliberative actions that the team has
taken and so it's important to keep in
mind that they still have several months
of work ahead of them their final report
will be released this summer and we will
publish it on our website
NASA believes that the study of
unidentified anomalous phenomena
represents an exciting step forward in
our quest to uncover the mysteries of
the world around us by embracing a
scientific lens we ensure that our work
is rigorous and reliable and by valuing
transparency and openness we can foster
trust and collaboration with the public
simply put this is why we do what we do
now before I introduce Nikki there are a
few administrative matters to attend to
firstly the unidentified anomalous
phenomena independent study team has
been established in accordance with the
federal advisory committee act known as
fako its parent committee is the earth
science advisory committees as such this
group does not report to the government
it reports to the earth science advisory
committee who'll debate the
recommendations and formally transmit
this team's report to the government
next our deliberative committee meetings
such as this one are open to the public
and also after this panel was convened
the National Defense authorization act
known as the ndaa changed the a in UAP
to be anomalous
accordingly this Pals remit was expanded
to Encompass not just aerial UAP
however the majority of UAP sightings to
date have been in the aerial domain so
it's fair to say that this panel's focus
is on the aerial aspect of anomalous
now in compliance with the fact of
federal statute formal minutes have been
taken throughout the meeting today and
these meetings and these minutes are for
the public record and hence all
presentations and discussions and
comments by the committee members should
be considered to be on the record
each member of this UAP study team has
been appointed because of their specific
subject matter expertise as individuals
and hence each member is subject to
Federal ethics laws
this category of appointment is called
special government employees or sges for
our non-government members and our two
federal employees
serve as regular government employees
known as rges
to the panel all members on this
committee should remember to recuse
themselves if a topic comes up in which
you have a potential conflict of
interest between your financial
interests including those of your
employer
and matters that we're discussing and
then finally panel if you have any
ethics questions please see me
separately and if needed I'll put you in
contact with the NASA ethics attorney
thanks for bearing with me I'd now like
to turn to the amazing Dr Nikki Fox
associate administrator for NASA's
science Mission directorate over to you
Nikki
thank you Dan and thank you to all the
members of NASA's UAP independent study
team your selfless dedication to the
pursuit of knowledge is just so
commendable and I want to thank you the
audience for tuning in today to watch
our first deliberative meeting of NASA's
independent study team on evaluating and
categorizing unidentified anomalous
phenomena
before I begin though I really do want
to double down on Dan's words that it is
really disheartening to hear of the
harassment that our panelists have faced
online all because they're studying this
topic
NASA stands behind our panelists and we
do not tolerate abuse harassment only
leads to further stigmatization of the
UAP field significantly hindering the
scientific progress and discouraging
others to study this important subject
matter
your harassment also obstructs the
Public's right to knowledge our
panelists are leading experts in the
scientific Aeronautics and data
analytics communities we are very lucky
to have them on board to share their
invaluable insights to inform NASA on
what possible data could be collected in
the future and how it can be collected
to help us better understand the nature
of UAP
the UAP independent study was
commissioned to create a road map on how
to use the tools of science to evaluate
and categorize the nature of uaps going
forward
this roadmap of course will help the
federal government obtain usable data to
explain the nature of future uaps
transparency openness and scientific
Integrity are Pinnacle to NASA's Mission
they're at the Forefront of this public
meeting and have been throughout the
team seven months on this study
as Dan noted this is a working meeting
and so the public will have the
incredible opportunity to witness the
process of Science in action
at Nasa we lead the world in Exploration
and are committed to rigorous scientific
inquiry
the nature of science is to better
understand the unknown and to do that
our scientists need data
right now there is very limited number
of high quality observations and data
curation of UAP
the existing data available from
eyewitness reports are often modeled and
cannot provide conclusive evidence that
supports UAP recognition and Analysis
additionally an object's background can
complicate the data further and render
it unusable due to Conventional objects
that can mimic or overshadow the
phenomena completely such as commercial
aircraft military equipment the weather
and ionospheric phenomena like auroras
this lack of high quality data make it
impossible to draw scientific
conclusions on the nature of UAP
now this team has used unclassified data
from civilian government entities
commercial data and data from other
sources to inform their recommendations
and as Dan noted they will be published
in a public report that comes out this
summer
I want to emphasize that there is really
great benefit to studying unclassified
data rather than classified data for
this study
first unidentified anomalous phenomena
sightings themselves are not classified
it's often the sensor platform that is
classified and you can kind of think of
it if a fighter jet took a picture of
the Statue of Liberty then that image
would be classified not because of the
subject in the picture but because of
the sensors on the plane
second unclassified data make it
possible for our team to communicate
openly to advance our understanding of
UAP not only with each other but across
the scientific community and to the
public
this ensures a clear and transparent
pipeline of information that can be
built upon through the general through
generations to expand our understanding
this study relies on open data
everything we use at Nasa is open and
anyone can look at these records so I
invite you to visit our open data portal
at
data.nasa.gov to comb through our tens
of thousands of data sets that are free
and fully accessible to the public
additionally please check out data.gov
open slash data for a great overview of
where you can find the archives for our
science and Mission data sites
I am very very much looking forward to
hearing the deliberations put forth
today from our distinguished panel of
experts thank you so much for being here
get off your phone
um before you've got a little just want
to open up to questions let me start
with a question on this oh on the NASA
data
um I think one of the important things
uh that we'll be looking at with other
data sets and events is the data is not
very well calibrated can you say just a
little bit about how NASA goes through
calibrating some of its earth science
data oh yes we very very rigorous Earth
site I mean all of our data sets not
just earth science go through extremely
rigorous calibration
um we don't release anything until it's
really perfect I mean we have quick look
data that is marked as quick look data
so you know you can use it to get
preliminary findings but wait for the
the really nicely cleaned up data so
a lot of rigorous protocol in putting
out our data to make sure it is perfect
do we have any other questions from the
panel
all right thank you so much
hi I'm David spurgle I'm the chair of
the panel
and when I look at our chart we have a
lengthy charge but the high level
summary of it is how can NASA contribute
to understanding the nature of uaps
and our role here
is not to resolve the nature of these
events but rather to give NASA guidance
to provide a road map of how it can
contribute in this area
after
my opening remarks we'll hear from Sean
kirpatrick from the aaro and it's the
aaro that's charged with leading the
whole of government UAP effort
and they've already issued some
preliminary reports on some of the
events
NASA's role is to use its unique
capabilities and its role as a civilian
agency interacting with the scientific
community in an open and transparent
manner
and you know as Dr Fox emphasized the
defense and intelligence agency data on
UAP
are often classified primarily because
of how the data is collected not because
what's in the data
the camera on an F-35 took a picture of
a bird it's classified
spy satellite takes an image of a
balloon
and we've had in the news some balloons
recently that date is classified
and that's because of a desire to not
reveal
our technical capabilities to other
nations
NASA on the other hand operates in a
mode where it's collecting data in the
open
and the NASA data is available on
websites and is well characterized and
because of NASA being the civilian
agency studying Air and Space it has a
special role to play
and I see our charge primarily as
helping identify for NASA ways that
could play that role and contribute to
understanding
we've gone through a preliminary data
collection stage
and to summarize some of the things that
we've learned
the current data collection efforts
regarding uaps are unsystematic
and fragmented across various agencies
often using instruments uncalibrated for
scientific data collection
and if I think about the data that
people have out there it's in many ways
what we'd like to think of as citizen
science but again it is uncalibrated
Data
um
poorly characterized not well curated
and we face looking through this data a
significant background a background of
many of these events are commercial
aircraft civilian America military
drones weather and research balloons
military equipment
ionospheric phenomenon we need to
characterize how
what the date when the date is taken
when it sees events like this first
the current existing data and eyewitness
reports alone are insufficient to
provide conclusive evidence about the
nature and origin of of every UAP event
they're often uninformative due to lack
of quality control and data curation
to understand UAP better
targeted data collection
thorough data curation and robust
analyzes are needed
such an approach will help to discern
unexplained UAP sightings
but even then there's no guarantee that
all sightings will be explained
another challenge in this area is what
we call stigma there's a real stigma
among people reporting events
and despite NASA's extensive efforts to
reduce the stigma the origin of the uaps
remain unclear and we feel many events
remain unreported
commercial pilots for example are very
reluctant
to report anomalies and one of our goals
in having NASA play a role is to remove
stigma and
get high quality data
in fact if I were to summarize
in one line what I feel we've learned
it's we need high quality data
and this is not some as a
research scientist whose work has been
primarily focused in cosmology
I would say the lesson of my career has
been you want to address important
questions you need high quality data
with well-calibrated instruments
so the let me now
introduce the agenda we're going to hear
from a number of experts who will be
presenting up to lunch
we'll then break at 12 for lunch from 12
to 12 30.
at 12 30 we'll resume
and we'll have presentations by members
of the panel on some preliminary ideas
for discussion
and that will be a period of time for
some open discussion by the panel
we will then have a q a session based on
questions that have been sent in in
advance to the website and we've curated
those questions and grouped them
together and we'll be going through a
lot of those questions and then we'll
summarize
and then over the subsequent uh couple
months we'll work on putting together
the report and as Dan said we're aiming
to make a public report available we
hope by the end of July
so uh now let me turn this over to Sean
Uncle Patrick
we'll do a couple q and A's probably
some Q A's for me okay from the panel
any any questions on the panel
thoughts yes we'll get the mic
yeah
um so one of the things I think Dr Fox
said was looking at the release of data
very important for our study when it's
high quality and you have also commented
that data are not always perfect when
we're doing certain studies I wonder if
you could
um shed some light on the you know the
difference between the application of
certain data to certain scientific
challenges
so you know when you look at your camera
your camera is often designed to take an
image in the daytime
and might not be optimized for nighttime
Imaging
or if you take something that
astronomers are very familiar with is we
design our telescopes to work at night
and if the Sun is not even if you can
you know you would never take the Hubble
telescope and point it at the Sun
this would destroy its detectors
not only that if the telescope is
pointing there
and the Sun is over there even though
you're not looking at the sun
Reflections off of the Optics will
produce what we call ghosting
and that kind of ghosting
gets produces some very strange images
and this you know one of the many things
we need to worry about when we see
unusual things taken from a camera
is even if you're pointing the camera
there was the sun over there
those kinds of anomalies degrade the
quality of the data and that's why it's
very important to work with
well-characterized instruments
and to be you know using them in ways in
which you you understand what's going on
so I think if you look at
you know data taken from the James Webb
Telescope or from the Hubble or any of
these things and these are you know
telescopes looking out in space you'll
see some really you know at first funny
phenomenon
when a telescope points at a star that's
bright
it saturates the detector and puts
bleeding down the detector
and you'll see phenomenon like if
there's a bright star off to the side
of the not even one you're looking at
you get this effects where light bounces
off of dust
in your telescope and produces a sort of
diffuse image that has some really
strange properties
so you know when you see something
unusual
the first thing you have to do is
understand how that data was taken
and I think this is one of the
challenges one faces when you have data
taken by uncalibrated instruments
years ago it's very hard to know what's
taken it's very hard to draw conclusions
I think that's one of the challenges
with archival data and I think having
dedicated well-calibrated instruments I
think will be important here is in any
other area to understand what's going on
so David anomalies are so often the
engine of Discovery maybe you could say
a quick word about high risk High reward
research in your field of cosmology and
how you see that impacting the UAP study
as well
so um
an area that comes to mind is on Fast
radial bursts
and Shaw prize was just announced
yesterday
and were awarded to the discovery of
fast radio bursts and these are these
bursting signals
that go off all over in space
and it's an interesting story because
some of the bursts were real
and are fascinating and some of the
births
there was a series of bursts observed by
this observatory in Australia
and they had really strange structure
and people couldn't figure out what was
going on
and then they start to notice a lot of
them bunched together around lunchtime
and what had happened was the uh
people at the observatory would heat up
their lunch in the microwave
and something they would do is they
would open the door of the microwave
oven
before the
microwave stopped
this is bad for your microwave oven
it wears it out but not only that It
produced a burst of radio signal that
was picked up by these sensitive
detectors
so
this I think is an interesting lesson
some events end up being something
unusual and conventional
but some events with these frbs turn out
to be these powerful explosions
which are taking place at cosmological
distances
their nature is still not fully
understood
I think they're one of the really most
fascinating objects we have these bursts
going out all over space
they're interesting Pros because they're
kind of lighting up space between here
and there and they're a subject of a
reactive research
and if I you know one looks at the
history of these frbs at first they were
discovered not believed and confirmly
confirmed and they were discovered by
instruments that were very sensitive but
not optimized for this
and now what we're doing is we're
optimizing instruments and optimizing
software to look for these events
and it's often these surprises that turn
out to be most interesting
and you know there are phenomenon like
Sprites which you can think of as upward
going lightning
which were seen by commercial pilots and
somewhat not believed right because they
were very strange and then and it was
really only when we were able to take
very high speed Imaging data data taken
often from places like space station
that were able to see that and learn
about these some fascinating ionospheric
phenomena so it's uh surprises are
really interesting I mean I think this
is
one of the
uh
fascinating things about the UAP
phenomenon if it's something that's
anomalous
that makes it interesting and worthy of
study
other questions
great
so now let me turn over to Sean
thank you David Dan
pleasure to be back good morning
everyone I want to start by thanking
NASA for convening today's
UAP independent study public meeting and
inviting me to continue to participate
NASA has been an invaluable partner to
our team at Arrow as we work to better
understand and respond to unidentified
anomalous phenomena
we applaud NASA for commissioning its
independent study team and for exploring
what data and tools could be leveraged
to shed greater light on UAP
though NASA and arrow are taking on very
different aspects of the UAP problem set
our efforts are very much complementary
we both are committed to the scientific
method to a data-driven approach
and the highest standards of scientific
research integrity
while NASA is evaluating unclassified
data sources for its study arrows data
set includes classified material with a
focus on National Security areas
however all of this data collectively is
critical to understanding the nature and
origin of UAP
NASA brings unique capabilities
world-class scientists and a wealth of
academic and research linkages
NASA also has access to Earth sensing
satellites
radiological sensors tools for
gravitational wave geomagnetic wave
detection and means for analyzing open
source cloud and crowdsource data that
may assist both Aero and NASA in their
UAP efforts
we are very grateful for the partnership
and welcome the opportunity to join with
NASA to share our Collective findings
with the public as the U.S government
moves towards greater transparency on
this issue
last month I testified before members of
the Senate armed services committee on
emerging threats and capabilities
and shared some of the progress made
since Arrow's establishment in July 2022
I discussed arrows scientific and
analytic approaches
its efforts to improve UAP data
collection standardize our reporting
processes leverage our Partnerships and
meticulously review the US government's
UAP related historical records
as I told the subcommittee then the
resolution of all UAP cases cannot be
accomplished by DOD and the intelligence
Community alone
era's ultimate success will require
Partnerships with the interagency
industry Academia the scientific
community and the public
which all bring their own resources
ideas and expertise to the UAP challenge
We Believe robust collaboration and peer
review
across a broad range of Partners will
promote greater objectivity and
transparency in the study of UAP
of course NASA's UAP independent study
team was convened very much in that
spirit
I also emphasized to Congress that the
only a very small percentage of UAP
reports displays signatures that could
reasonably be described as anomalous
the majority of unidentified objects
reported to Arrow and in our Holdings
demonstrate mundane characteristics of
readily explainable sources
while a large number of cases in arrows
Holdings remain technically unresolved
this is primarily due to a lack of data
associated with those cases
very much along the lines of what David
was just speaking about
without sufficient data we are unable to
reach defendable conclusions that meet
the high scientific standards we set for
resolution
meanwhile for the few objects that do
demonstrate potentially anomalous
characteristics arrows approaching these
cases with the highest level
of objectivity and analytic rigor this
includes physical testing and employing
modeling and simulation to validate our
analyzes and the underlying theories and
then peer reviewing those results before
reaching any conclusions
Arrow has shared these cases with the
appropriately cleared NASA team members
in order to discuss and help recommend
potential scientific areas of study that
NASA may want to take lead on
I'll underscore here as I did before
Congress at Arrow's work will take time
if we are committed to doing it right
arrow is committed to the highest
standards of scientific research
Integrity as we know our partners at
Nasa are as well
thanks again to NASA for hosting this
public forum for UAP discussion and
information exchange and I'd like to
turn to a brief presentation that
includes some recently Declassified
footage and trends for discussion
next slide please
so if some of you probably saw a version
of this at the open hearing last month
this is an overall
review of all the analytic trends of all
the cases that we have to date while the
numbers may have changed a little bit
um the overall Trends remain the same
most of what we are seeing reported by
aircraft are at the altitudes where we
fly aircraft that should not be a
surprise
you will note however that I have no
space reports and I have no Maritime
reports
that is notable even though we are
looking across all of those domains
on the upper right we have UAP
morphologies the vast majority of what
has been reported and what we have data
on a little less than half now are orbs
round spheres
and in the bottom right you will see in
the really the the Heats map of the
areas where we get most of our reporting
this is very much a collection biased
map this is where our sensors are our
military and Ric and some of the FAA
data
in the middle it is what we call our
typical UAP characteristics for the vast
majority of the cases that we see
one way of looking at that is a is a
we'll call it a Target package this is
the thing we are out hunting for in most
cases
next slide please
this is an example of one that I showed
at the hearing recently this is a
spherical orb metallic in the Middle
East 2022 by an MQ-9
and we'll come back to the sensor
question that David raised here in a
moment
this is a typical example of the thing
that we see most of we see these all
over the world and we see these in and
making very interesting
apparent maneuvers
this one in particular however I would
point out demonstrated no enigmatic
technical capabilities and was no threat
to Airborne safety
while we are still looking at it I don't
have any more data other than that
and so being able to come to some
conclusion is going to take time until
we can get better resolved data on
similar objects that we can then do a
larger analysis on
next slide please
I'm going to let this play through this
is a newly released video you'll notice
there are two dots moving back and forth
there is a plane at the bottom that's
moving across the screen and now there
are three dots moving back and forth
the moving back and forth is from the
sensor and the platform that's
collecting it this is a a P3 on a
training mission in the Western United
States they picked these up and they
tried to intercept and was unable to
intercept them
apart from that motion and you'll see a
little bit of defocusing from the sensor
itself
there is no other
Oddity about this except for the fact
that they couldn't catch them the reason
they couldn't catch them is because
after further analysis it was shown that
those objects were actually much farther
away from the P3 than they thought
and in fact when we went even deeper
looked at Air Traffic Control Data we
were able to match those to aircraft on
a major flight Corridor heading into a
major airport for landing
this is the kind of thing that can
spoof and or provide misperception of
both very highly trained pilots as well
as sensors
right and this was reported as an odd
grouping of three UAP
all right
that is not to say that the pilots
didn't know what they were looking at or
they they knew what they were looking at
but they weren't really sure but it also
is meant to say that when they're not
sure they're reporting it now and that's
what they're supposed to be doing and
then we have to go look at it
[Music]
next slide please
that brings us to really what is Arrow
doing in the science and Technical
Realms so this is one of those areas
that
I'm going to expound a little bit more
on than we did in the last hearings
Arrow has a
robust scientific plan that we are
required to then provide to Congress
here pretty soon
one of the first things that we're doing
is looking across all the existing
sensor data against that typical UAP
Target that I gave you up at the very
first slide that goes beyond DOD and IC
sensors that's commercial that's civil
that's in with partnership with NASA
with NASA sensors and NOAA sensors
understanding if any of these Earth
sensing satellites any of these Airborne
platforms any of these ground Radars
whether it's FAA or other can actually
see these things
given what we've got so far is going to
be an important first step to
understanding which sensors are going to
be relevant
from there we will we are augmenting
with dedicated sensors that we've
purposed built designed to detect track
and characterize those particular
objects we will be in putting those out
in very select areas for surveillance
purposes
Partnerships with Academia exploring the
signatures to match to our data so
understanding if a thing is moving and
if it is doing certain anomalous
activities what are the signatures we
would expect to see how do we pull on
that and then from there how do I tune
my collection architecture to go after
it
statistical analytic techniques we're
working with a couple of universities on
how do I do broader base statistical
analysis on unclassified and classified
data so that I can apply those analytics
to our Holdings
and then Ai and ml analytic techniques
for searching out through the data what
are this what are the objects what are
the targets that we're going after
we have Partnerships with both DOD and
doe labs to explore our current
state-of-the-art fundamental physics of
UAP observations
both current and historical in other
words if I have objects those few that
are doing some things that are anomalous
what is our current understanding of
maneuverability
speed
signature management
propulsion what are those underlying
signatures that we would expect to see
and how do I then pull on that
our interagency and Allied partnership
ships for calibration of our
capabilities this is exactly what David
was pointing at the vast majority of
what we have reported to us are DOD
sensors DOD sensors are not scientific
sensors they are not intelligence
Community sensors Believe It or Not
intelligence Community sensors are very
close to Scientific sensors they are
calibrated they are high Precision they
are everything you'd ever want to know
about a thing
DOD sensors have one purpose they are to
identify an object that is known and put
a weapon on it
that is what they're for right
predominantly so understanding how do
you calibrate those against these known
objects how do I fly in F-35 against a
weather balloon at different speeds and
different altitudes and different Sun
conditions and different lighting
conditions and and heating conditions
those are all important measurements
that need to be done and we are on the
in process of doing that right now that
table on the right is a very simplified
version of our entire test Matrix which
you would not be able to fit on three of
these slides against all of our sensors
across all of those phenomenologies
that will be useful in order to then
train our operators pilots and sensors
against the known objects
and then finally our pattern of Life
analysis
this is essentially baselining what is
normal I have all these Hot Spot areas
but we only have hotspot areas because
that's when the reports come in from The
Operators that are operating at that
time
they don't operate all the time
so to have a 24 7 collection monitoring
campaign in some of these areas for
three months at a time is going to be
necessary in order to measure out what
is normal then I'll know what is not
normal
when we have additional things that come
through those spaces
and that includes space and maritime
next slide please
which brings me to some of my
recommendations for the panel and their
consideration and deliberation
um
some of these we're going to be
exploring with our our new NASA embed
I'm happy to be welcoming on for your
pretty soon who's going to help us in
our scientific plan
um
crowdsourcing unclassified open source
data this is where you know some of the
public can be helpful you know
imagery from a iPhone is generally not
helpful unless you are right up on
whatever it is you're looking at
however some of the ancillary data that
your iPhone provides from location to
speed to you know other
phenomenologies and more than one of
those can be very helpful
right
large-scale ground-based scientific
instrumentation
evaluating
how can I use some of these other
instruments for detection the frb
example was was perfect right you have a
bunch of large scales
instruments that were not designed for
that yet they picked them up because
there was a microwave
well we have a a surrogate Target
package of what we think these things
are at least from a what we've got
reported to us that was in the front
slide
understanding how can I evaluate that
against all of these other instruments
and do any of them have a chance of
picking anything up that would be
helpful in tipping and queuing us to get
other sensors on target
I think leading that evaluation of the
scientific ground-based sensors would be
useful also the same thing for the Earth
Sciences satellites as we mentioned
before
intentional Vice coincidental collection
so
looking at how can I provide a tip and
cue to both the ground and space-based
scientific and academic sensor Community
to put additional sensors on a object
when it is reported I'm currently doing
that with arrow The Joint staff the
commands for when they get tip in queue
right so a pilot says something they see
something they report it in and we're
going to turn on a whole bunch of new
collection to go after it I should be
able to hand that same tip and cue to
the scientific and academic community
so looking at how that works would be
helpful
peer reviewing Advanced capabilities the
parameterization and the publication of
that that have not yet been engineered
we understand a lot of fundamental
physics it is the scientific
community's responsibility to explore
and document those fundamentals and
peer-reviewed scientific journals to
match to data so that we can weed out
all kinds of different hypotheses right
that's how science works we need to make
sure that we are doing that I think
leading that conversation would be very
helpful from NASA's perspective
archived scientific data so we have a
whole bunch of calibrated large-scale
scientific data from all these different
instrumentations around the world taking
a look at how can you apply some maybe
some AIML tools to search through that
data for anomalous signatures that may
correlate to things that we've got
reporting on that would be an
interesting study
distributions of sightings I think this
is a low hanging fruit one right so if
we take a look at all of the
distributions of sightings that are
outside of my National Security areas
that I've got classified reporting for
and they generate the similar
distribution map as we've got and we put
those two pieces together now I have a
holistic picture
and then of course our foreign
Partnerships building a robust
scientific community of Interest review
data capabilities conduct analysis
expanding upon you know our military and
intelligence collaborations across the
world into the scientific and academic
world
and with that those were my thoughts
we've talked about some of these in the
past it would be interesting to to hear
if there's any further questions or
deliberations on any of those points and
I'm happy to take any questions that you
all have
great uh thank you Dr Kirkpatrick and I
also want to you take this opportunity
to thank you in the Aro for your
openness uh in providing this committee
with insight and information about what
you've learned so far how we could work
together I think this is very much an
area where it's going to be essential
that NASA be a partner and be a good
partner for aaro and I think you're uh
really want to thank you for your role
with this Committee in helping to start
to build that partnership it's been my
pleasure and let's uh Reggie
um question we talked a lot about data
already
let's talk about sensors for a second so
you mentioned that you work with Labs
Academia
do you see a need to go beyond what you
mentioned earlier that is the type of
census we have right now which are based
on National Security threats and certain
phenomenologies and frequency range of
these kinds of things do you see a
reason of going beyond that yep
absolutely what what are some of the
challenges you see there materials
so can we go back to the front slide
just the first slide where the target
characterization is
so we've we've purpose built a couple of
of sensors to do search
across that nope down one there you go
that's great to go down some of those
characteristics to see if we can find
them correlated to Pilot reporting all
right
some of those are
initially this is going to be I'm going
to say this is a bootstrap method right
we're doing a broad spectrum search
across very few indicators that we can
point to that will enable us to get a
little bit more data refine that narrow
Those sensors and and and go from there
so we aren't just relying on the dod and
IC sensors that exist today because
frankly they don't point to where we
want them to point right I mean I'll be
frank with with everyone
we we can point the largest
collection apparatus in the entire Globe
at any point we want
you just have to tell me where I want to
point it
second piece of that is a lot of what we
have is is around the continental United
States
most people including the government
don't like it when I point our entire
collection apparatus to your backyard
right it's it's not allowed we have some
laws about that and we've got to figure
out how to do this only in the areas
that that I can get high confidence
there's going to be something there
and high confidence I'm not going to
break any laws doing it
so there's a there's a trade there so
some of these ground-based Point
detectors are going to be necessary for
that to point up to point out to search
coupled with we're evaluating a number
of sensor opportunities across different
organizations Academia
industry whatnot that that already exist
or are being built for similar purposes
or maybe other purposes that I might be
able to recalibrate for this and see if
those will have a chance of of seeing
that Target right so that's where the
modeling and Sim comes in can I can I
take that Target put it into your sensor
and have a chance of seeing it
if I can then I might want to use it
yo wait
who's next are you Nadia
um thanks Sean I have the questions you
probably don't want which are about
numbers unless I miss them during your
presentation
uh you had said that only a very small
percentage of your cases display
signatures that could be anomalous and
Then followed that up with the few
objects that do demonstrate potentially
anomalous characteristics
what numbers are we talking about how
big is your database how many years was
it collected over and uh were those
observations made and then by few what
do you mean right no that's a great
question so this chart as I mentioned
we've updated with our current data
Holdings at the time of my open hearing
we were at
650 cases-ish
we are now over 800.
we are putting together our annual
report which will be due August 1 to the
hill and in it and there will be an
unclassified version as there always has
been we will have those updated numbers
at that time
we roughly get I mean you can do the
math you know it depends anywhere from
from 50 to
100-ish new reports a month now the
reason we had such a big jump recently
is because I got faa's data integrated
in finally and so we ended up with like
100 and some odd new cases
um so there's there's a reason why it's
going to fluctuate the numbers that I
would say so
um
we're gonna we're gonna try to do a
little more uh
Fidelity on some of the analytics when
we report out
but the numbers I would say that we see
are
possibly really anomalous are less than
single digit percentages of those that
total database so maybe
two to five-ish percent
all right
I'll stand up because I'm on the other
end of the room
um thanks Sean for your presentation and
for the some of the video footage that
we saw
um while we're all good scientists on
this panel I think that I look at it
with an untrained eye of looking at that
video and so I see three spots moving
and everything else in the background
looks like it's stable can you talk a
little bit more about either the sensor
platform or what we're seeing that's
stable in the background because they've
been identified as airplanes and
there's clear description of of from
other data sources that came in to help
clarify that but when I look at this
what are all of the white spots in the
background that we're seeing that are
stable
so those are these that's a star
background
pretty sure that's star background
now so you're looking at those planes
were roughly
um
30 to 40-ish miles away if I remember
correctly and when you see that smaller
plane that comes in at the bottom
that one was much much closer it was
like maybe
six to ten miles away
right and so the Jitter in the sensor is
is what you're looking at
right okay so the three spots because
they look like they're moving at about
the same right they are right and and if
they were flying together but they're
not is what I'm hearing they're in the
center they're in a flight line right so
they're equally spaced in a flight line
and the sensor is jittering thank you
yes appreciate that yes
okay if you go to your first slide if
you don't mind not the title slide but
the the trends the trends yeah
um it's the previous slide there you go
thank you so
I want to make sure I understand the
slide it says typically reported
characteristics and there are a bunch of
things here like for example size
altitude speed if it's being observed
from a single sensor
use the example of like the airplanes
that were coming in and if you don't
know how far away they are how do you
assess the size how do you assess the
speed
um
this is what people would report but it
isn't necessarily what is the real size
of the object or the speed or the rest
of it do I understand that correctly
partially okay so you this is not all
single sensor observations some of these
are very much multi-sensor observations
and this is parameterized to cover the
range of things for any given parameter
the range of of what's possible and what
is
been observed okay and then on the next
Slide the one where you've got the or is
the meatball moving across the the
screen that one
um
so
was there any look at
sensor artifact data processing artifact
I mean
the first thing that whenever I say
anything that's anomalous I look at how
is the data collected yeah
so yes these are these are so this is an
EO sensor on an MQ-9
and we understand that very very well
that is that is a real object
absolutely
and memory
you also use AI ml techniques or
existing data sets or possibly some of
them open source can you explain a
little bit more what kind of AI ml
techniques you are using are these about
anomaly detection or using anything
related to natural language processing
or using anything related to computer
vision
so we're looking at a number of
different
capabilities that span I think a lot of
what you've just said so we've got
um we haven't applied it yet we are
researching how we're going to apply it
so natural language processing for the
reports from Pilots absolutely
Target recognition so I can train a
model to look for that thing and go back
through all of our Holdings and go give
me how many of these you have right
and then try to figure out what those
are right so I have not put anything out
there yet or have not looked at anything
yet for
active targeting in real time because I
don't know exactly what I would train it
to go look for I just know what we have
so I want to get more confidence on what
we have before I go and do that except
for balloons all right we're trying to
get rid of balloons as quickly as
possible
so Sean I just wanted to begin by
thanking you for your service to this
nation this committee you don't exactly
have the easiest job in Washington no I
do not appreciate it I'm glad I don't
recognize that we certainly do I also
want to commend you noting the
international Partnerships Spain just
signed the Artemis Accords yesterday the
increasing the membership to 25 I think
that's a global partnership that you
could leverage only 170 more countries
to go excellent everyone signed up I
just have two questions one relative to
what Nadia was asking about the number
of anomalous phenomena what makes it
anomalous in your view what is the
phenomenology where you're pulling those
cases out and saying this is truly
unexplained and then my second question
would be relative to the stigma how
damaging is that in your view and what
in particular do you think NASA can do
to help remedy the situation
that's a great question so I'm going to
take this second one first because I
know we're getting short on time
the the stigma has improved
significantly over the years since the
Navy first took this on
some years ago
it is not gone and in fact I would argue
the stigma exists inside
the leadership of all of our our
buildings right wherever that is
um
my team and I have also been subject to
lots of harassment especially coming out
of my last hearing because people don't
understand the scientific method and why
it why we have to do the things we have
to do
right and because we can't just come out
and say you know the greatest the
greatest thing that could happen to me
is I could come out and say hey I know
where all these things are here you go
all right but I don't right and it's
going to take us time to research all
that
um
people want answers now and so they are
they're actually feeding the stigma by
by exhibiting that kind of behavior to
all of us right that is that is a bad
thing where can NASA help I made that
recommendation on NASA should lead the
scientific discourse we need to elevate
this conversation
all right we need to have this
conversation in an open environment like
this where we aren't going to get
harassed
because this is a hard problem it is a
hard target problem we need to
understand what is the things that are
in all of our domains space or air or
undersea and how do we make sense of
that
um
your first question on what makes it
anomalous to me we actually developed
some definitions on all of these things
we gave it both to the White House and
to Congress I think we've got some of
that into law now but essentially
anomalous is anything that is not
readily
understandable by the operator or the
sensor
right so it is doing something weird
whether that's maneuvering
Against the Wind at Mach 2 with no
apparent propulsion or it's
um
going into the water which we have we
have shown is not the case that is
actually a sensor anomaly that we've now
figured out and we're going to be
publishing all that
you know those kinds of things
make anomalous signature we'll call it
signature management but it's things
that are
not
readily understandable in the context of
hey I've got a thing that's out in the
light
it should reflect a certain amount of
if it doesn't reflect that amount of
light something weird
I think we have time for one last
question
I did a foreign partnership with NASA
I'm curious especially given your mat
have you as era partnered with
International agencies and those are
ways for reporting to your
so that's that's a great question I want
to expound on that just a little bit so
I have just held uh our first five eyes
Forum on this subject
um last week I think it was or earlier
this week I don't know Dan was there uh
and we
have ex you know we've we've entered
into discussions with our partners on
data sharing how do they do reporting
what kind of analysis can they help us
with what kind of calibration can they
help us with what can we help them with
and we're establishing all of that right
now and they're going to end up you know
sending their information and data to us
to feed into the process that we've laid
out for how we're going to to do all
this
um
beyond that I have not had either the
time or the bandwidth to do and that's
why I would look to NASA to expand the
scientific and and
academic relationships that they have
across all of our allies and partners on
how can we bring them into the fold
that's where I think there's a lot of
benefit to NASA taking lead on that
great uh thank you but um one just
clarifications for people who don't know
what are the five R's oh I'm sorry for
those of you that aren't familiar with
the five eyes those are uh that's the UK
Canada
um Australia New Zealand and the United
States so those are the five partners
terrific so thank you very much thank
you
so our next presentation is from Mike
free on from the FAA talking about the
faa's role and what's learned
would like to thank the panel for the
opportunity to come and give an overview
of the FAA and and some data points
around the faa's mission the data the fa
provides to provide the framing of what
are the surveillance systems that we can
bring to bear or their there's data
around Those sensors as well as to frame
the limitations of those I know Sean
talked about some of the data points
that uh that are used and being
integrated so hopefully this will give
you an overview of the fa's mission as
well as as well as those data points
next slide please
so the the faa's mission is is quite
large and complex by by a factor of two
we operate uh more commercial aircraft
than any other country I think we're
second only to Australia in total
airspace but largely because Australia
has a very large Oceanic volume that
they're responsible for for managing so
it is a very complex very large National
airspace system
uh we have four over fourteen thousand
controllers uh 520 Air Traffic Control
Towers which are located at the the
highest density of airports and I've
referred to those as towers and and
subsequent slides
we have 147 what we call terminal radar
approach controls or traycons and those
are manned
control facilities at the high and
medium density airports around the
nation as well as 21 air Route traffic
control centers which are which manage
the control of air traffic in the
enroute environment
there's 19 000 over 19 000 airports five
thousand over five thousand of those are
associated to public airports with the
remaining fourteen thousand plus private
airports
next slide please
so the faa's mission is primarily around
safe and efficient control of manned
aircraft that has been her our
historical Mission and and remains our
primary Mission certainly as we talk
about a new entrance with uas's and
Advanced Air mobility and some of those
things there will be an evolution of the
fa's mission to include safe operation
of the nass with those those new
entrants but the architecture and design
of the Nas is is geared around safe and
efficient control of aircraft and manned
aircraft
the certainly the the commercial aspect
the commercial flights are a primary
focus of the agency we certainly support
general aviation and flights as well
um but again our mission is around Maine
aircraft and safe and an efficient
operation of those
um the uh by the Numbers uh over 16
million flights yearly 5400 flights uh
at Peak any given uh at the peak of time
of any given day uh 45
000 daily flights 25 million GA flight
hours per year a very large very complex
operation that that we're responsible
for managing we certainly provide a
significant contribution to to that for
that service to to the nation in the
form of uh in the product toward a GDP
next slide
so as we get into the discussion of
surveillance Services I want to provide
a little bit of framework around the
categorization of our surveillance
services and we primarily break those
into two two bodies The Cooperative
surveillance which is defined by a
sensor that's avionics or equipment on
board the aircraft that works in
conjunction with ground-based sensors
the non-cooperative surveillance is
independent this is basically the
classic radar RF energy is transmitted
out reflects off the Target and we
receive that signal and from that return
we can determine where that data that
aircraft is
typically these cooperative and
non-cooperative sensors are co-located
together one The Cooperative mounted on
top of the non-cooperative radar
so for the purpose from a data
perspective I think in this this panel
in the study I I think that the
Cooperative sensors those are neither
unknown or anomalous so for the purposes
of this this briefing or the rest of
this briefing I'm going to focus on the
the non-cooperative aspect
next slide please
so the again from the standpoint of the
mission of the FAA around it again is is
primarily around manned aircraft and I
think that serves as an important
framework for the data points and the
type of data that we can bring to pair
for this panel so we break our our
systems and the design of the systems
into different types of systems so we
have short range Radars which are
typically located at the high and medium
density airports and those operate from
a range I have a detection range between
40 and 60 miles and an altitude
detection capability of about 24 000
feet
the long-range radar systems have a
detection range of two to 250 nautical
miles with altitude detection up to 100
000 feet so that provides the basic the
framework for for those I will mention
uh the automatic dependence surveillance
broadcast or adsb only from a context
that that does serve as a primary data
source and a preferred data source for
the management of the airspace system
but it is a Cooperative system and for
the purposes of the next slides as I get
into the discussion of the coverage and
the type of detection for those
non-cooperative targets it is not
considered as part of those
and also surface surveillance is also
something that we provide but again for
the purpose of the study I only include
those for just a completeness
perspective
the one final Point as I talk about
manned aircraft and primary emission
for the
drones and balloons and things of that
nature their basic premise is to operate
in a not to interfere basis that they
are not to interfere with the band
operations and that's that's a
fundamental aspect as we talk to the
data and what we can and can detect with
respect to those non-band non-manned
systems
next slide please
realizing this is an eye chart this I
would wanted to provide just a a
graphical or pictorial depiction of
where our sensors are located uh the
green blue and pink balloons if you will
represent our short range Radars those
are are located at at airports those are
where those are are cited
the the two reddish balloons they have
letters in them a four and a c
those represent our long-range Radars
the rc4s and karser systems that are
used in in the context of both from an
air traffic control perspective as well
as for a National Defense and Homeland
Security emission
and the the
perimeter the Archer 4S are located
around the perimeter of the country
equally spaced and the karsha systems
are located on the interior of of the
U.S I will point out that this only
depicts the conus there are systems ATC
both short range and long-range systems
Hawaii Alaska and Caribbean
uh those are not depicted here
um I don't think they were necessary for
the uh the the purpose of understanding
the surveillance
um and I will also point out that both
for this slide and the subsequent
coverage slide we I do not talk to any
classified DOD or DHA systems than an
operation
next slide please
so what it is what can the fa detect and
surveil what can can we not this slide
gives you a buy altitude slice of what
it is that we can detect so if you look
at the the
Square that's labeled a thousand foot
AGL
that depicts by sensor for an aircraft
that is a thousand feet in altitude what
is the range at which we can detect that
aircraft
and so on as you get higher in altitude
or further higher in altitude you can
detected at further range and that's
basically a phenomenon of the curvature
of the Earth in the line of sight aspect
of these these radar systems so pretty
good coverage across the the us at 10
000 feet and above
this is a mathematical model based of a
pure line of sight as well as some
geographical screening as you can see in
the western part of the U.S there are
there is screening and due to the
mountains and Those sensors
need to take a little bit of time and
talk about the the nature of the targets
these line of sight models
represent an input of a Target that is
one square meter so think of a sphere of
one meter in diameter that's the
assumption that goes into these models
so if you think about that in the
context of other forms or aircraft a
fourth generation F-15 or F-18 is in the
proximity of about one square meter
perhaps a little bit larger
a large airliner is perhaps a 100 square
meters
a small uas
is perhaps
one or a 0.01 square meter so the range
of these detections or the or the size
and the ability to check these targets
from an F-15 large airliner 100 times
larger in size a drone a hundred times
smaller in size so the detection
of and a surveillance capability really
largely depends in part to the the
Target that we're talking about and the
ability to surveil that Target
all right next slide
so I do include this adsb coverage slide
just to give a context of from a
Cooperative perspective there is very
good coverage across the U.S to without
a 1 500 feet above ground level so this
provided context of what when we look at
the data and start getting a discussion
of what it is we can detect this will
certainly for those Cooperative aircraft
that have adsb we could certainly detect
those to a pretty a pretty low altitude
across across the U.S
all right a couple of data points I
think um I know Sean certainly talked
about some of the data points and I can
provide a little bit of insight from an
fa perspective
drones drones are a pretty significant
challenge there's 880 000 registered
drones in the U.S
small drones I should say part 107
drones
many tens of thousands of those are
operate operated on a daily basis for by
commercial operators it's not clear how
many private drone operators are taking
their their drone up for a quick flight
um but as I said earlier those are
regulated
by uh they're regulated to operate below
400 feet in altitude so again it's the
Drone aspect is for those small drones
in particular and as well as all of all
classes of drones there are regulatory
restrictions to where they can and
cannot fly basically avoiding and not
interfering with manned aircraft
operations
second data point we talked about
balloons The Weather Service we know on
190 or 92 weather stations that release
balloons twice a day
at 6 a.m and and
our zero zero hundred Zulu and 1200 Zulu
typically two hour duration they fly up
to 100 000 feet where the envelope
bursts and and then the payload descends
back back to Earth so certainly
um you know 100 at least 184 balloon
flights daily in the nas you know not to
consider universities and hobbyist
balloons that that may be launched but
those are typically small small in size
and finally uh Sean did talk about uaps
and NFA data a couple of data points
that we do report there is a process by
which air traffic controllers can report
UAP sightings or or events uh
historically those have been in the
range of about three to five reports per
month that have been reported we did see
an uptick of of reports in August of 22
that went up to about eight to ten
perhaps due to startling starlink
launches
and finally the
with the Chinese weather or the Chinese
balloon incident in February we did see
a significant up tip an uptick and
there's like 68 UAP reports that started
in February and we've seen a large
number you know subsequent to them to
that
I think that's all I had
um any questions
do you want to take the question it's
easy actually you can call choose the
questioners it's easy
yeah so two questions two questions
about the uh the the radar data coverage
first one is do you retain any of the
data or is it
um
cycled over as there is a retention and
long-term retention of data I can't
recall exactly how long retain that is
certainly a requirement from a retention
from a
legal perspective exactly but I do know
there is some periodicities in a
measured in a term of months is it
retained in terms of like the raw radar
or is some processed form of data that's
retained I believe it's a process form
of data that is what was displayed on
the uh whether it's in Indian root eram
system or the star system and then the
other question is for The Radars are
they operated in any sort of a tasked
mode or are they constant search the
current systems in our inventory just
their their fixed face and they just
rotate at either 12 RPM or 5 RPM
depending on whether it's an enroute or
a terminal surveillance okay thanks
requirement all right next question yes
per month per month
that is three to five reports per month
for all the controllers in all of the US
so there's a process by which if they
see something and they want to report
that they can go to report that to the
the then we call it but uh report hey I
saw something I don't know what it was
so it's three to five per month across
the entire you have 14 000 controllers
per month so
you know 45
000 operations any given day
30 months 30 days however many days in a
month you know it's a very small
percentage
uh
bribe actually about this how do you do
you encourage to report do you feel like
the stigma on uaps is impairing the
reporting yeah I'm not aware of
I'll answer it this way
um the the process by which UAP is
reported is part of the air traffic
controller order so basically the
aircraft controllers are allowed it says
you know if you see something here's a
process by which the procedure by which
you would report it other than that I'm
not aware of any any specific stigma or
or limitations and I really probably not
in a good position to you know to speak
to that other than there is that process
and that is the process that we used and
is what represents those numbers I
talked to and if I may have had a
question prior to this one how do you
decide the sites where you deploy you
saw the map and it has some very good
coverage on the coastal areas there were
some areas of lack of coverage yeah so
if we want if you go back go back one
slide from what's presented here
um the what you'll see is in the eastern
half of the US there's a lot better
coverage but that's because there's a
lot more population in the East and
therefore a lot more airports and these
systems are historically cited at the
airport the support of those those
airport operations to the West obviously
oops to less less dense and fewer
systems now the that's from an ASR the
short range radar perspective the long
range Radars are pretty much equally
spaced to provide in order to provide
the maximum coverage from a Homeland
defense and security perspective as well
as with a higher altitude flights the
enroute
Cruise phase of air traffic control
Warren
Mike first thank you in the fa for
coming to share this information with us
second uh can you speak to a little bit
uh of the filtering techniques that we
use so with respect to I know Walter had
a question about the raw data and
process but can you just talk a little
bit about we actually aren't trying to
detect everything you know that's
actually a very good question and a very
good point with respect to what we can
and cannot see so there are you know the
closer to the ground you point a radar
certainly you can get lower elevations
but you also start to see the effects of
trees and other ground-based clutter as
we call it that starts to interfere so
we we have great ability to detect a lot
of things but but from an fa Mission
perspective our desire is to find that
sweet spot of seeing everything to as
low in altitude as we can
um to maximize our mission around safe
operations of manned aircraft
now to pull that thread just a little
bit further you know there's also
limitation with respect to Biologicals
or insects and dust and things of this
this flavor that most aircraft Fly Above
a certain speed so we typically will
have filtering settings on our systems
to get rid of the stuff that really is
leaves or insects or things of that
nature so that we provide as clean a a
display for the controllers so there are
specific settings that we we can can
adjust and it's been learned over many
years to perfect those what we call
optimization
of those kinds of filters to get rid of
what is not a manned aircraft not an
aircraft and and provide as clean a
display for the controllers as we can
yes
yeah please thanks
um thank you thanks for the presentation
um would it be kind of fun what you said
Warren
um would it be possible to
um to collect the raw data and to save
that because if if it would be possible
to do some calibration after the fact
that Sean was mentioned for example you
might be to capture other phenomenology
is that possible well when you say raw
data I think you'd have we'd have to
talk a little bit about what is meant um
so you know what from a technical
perspective pure what we would call inq
data is huge huge you know gigabyte very
very very large volumes of data that
would probably be cost prohibitive and
we certainly don't do that today
um the there are again we do record data
but it is effectively the data that is
has been through some form of these
processes in these filterings we do that
today
um but it it certainly with enough time
and money we could certainly collect
that data and I think it but it would be
a we'd have to look at the challenge of
in of how we would go about modifying
the systems or introducing new ways to
collect that that raw data as you as you
described certainly it's feasible it's
possible but it's not without technical
challenge
yes 184 balloon flights daily are those
characterized or they just you just know
they do that and then they end up where
they are so under the balloon I'll call
it part 101 the regulations for balloons
there's very specific requirements so
for National Weather Service before they
release those they'll contact the local
Air Traffic facility they're going to
say here's what time I'm going to
release it and when they release it they
have tracking and they provide that
tracking to the air traffic control
facility throughout the flight of of you
know that particular blend there are
commercial balloons that are also
launched but those most for the most
part as I understand that have they
actually transmit their GPS position
it's support of where they're flying so
as to ensure they're not interfering
with with their traffic and to ensure
they are traffic controllers are aware
of where those those balloons are
operating
yes ma'am
um from traffic control but what about
from the non-cooperative surveillance
has there been anomalies from the
sensors themselves and if so what is the
process for that
I'd say the fa mission is not around
anomalies with the the non-cooperative
sensors themselves so as we build an air
traffic control picture we we have both
the non-cooperative systems which
detects the target we have a Cooperative
system that also detects a Target and we
will tend to merge those those
targets together and so on a
controller's display they'll know is
this a non-cooperative only or emerged
or combined Target so that they know you
know basically an increased level of
confidence that on what it is are seeing
is in fact a real aircraft so we don't
just make any real distinction between a
non-cooperative and a Cooperative other
than how they get combined and put on a
controller's display so I don't know if
that answered
uh so it's like a ga flight that does
that is flying visual flight rules those
will just be picked up by the if they're
even if they don't if they're not
equipped with with a court with a
Cooperative avionics those would just be
picked up by the non-cooperative system
that if they happen to surveil where
that aircraft is is flying and so that
certainly will be put on the
controller's display and they will be
able to provide
awareness in fact there's a flight
following a procedure by which GA Pilots
can ask for hey I'm not I'm not
squawking I don't have a Cooperative
system
but please help me and just via the
radio I'm going to going from here to
here and and providing awareness uh
situational awareness if the controller
has the bandwidth to to provide that
data
one last question yes so I'm not a
scientist I'm a recovering attorney and
I love process and a few questions there
if I'm a pilot where do I find that
process for reporting uaps where is that
articulated or captured second When you
mention that you're reporting these
incidents who are you reporting it to
and are those incidents pulling on the
thread that Reggie started are they
being archived anywhere I believe they
are archived they're reported to the
domestic Network event Network it's an
fa organization or or function
I don't I can't speak to whether for
whether they would be say part of what
Sean would would include as part of his
database I presume so
um so I can think that was the answer to
the second question uh what was the
first question again I'm sorry where
does the reporting process live if I'm a
pilot I see a uip where do I go to find
out that I don't know the answer to that
question I said I'm familiar with the
reporting process from a controller
perspective and the order that's that's
used to define how controllers do their
job I am not I I don't know the answer
to the question from a pilot perspective
that's yeah
activities
great so uh thank you Mike for your
presentation and uh for the all the help
the FAA has given us as we've been
learning more about the very impressive
system
that the FAA maintains uh thank you I
know you know for me one of the many
takeaways from this is uh filling it you
know just a little bit safer every time
I fly I'm thankful for you and your
colleagues for what they do to make that
possible
thank you and we're now going to take a
quick lunch break we'll be back at 12
30.
um and uh
see you all soon
series of short presentations by members
of the panel and their thoughts on
different aspects of our charge
and the format is we're going to have
them come up to the podium and speak
and I'm going to ask each of the
speakers then to take questions it's
actually the angle with this setup is
you you can see the people better from
the podium than I can where it's hard to
see people behind you
um I'm going to try to keep manage the
time so as those questions you know come
to an end I'll cut you off and bring up
the next speaker
and uh we'll move through the the six
topics and then we'll have some time at
the end for some general discussion
uh the first speaker will be Dr Nadia
Drake talking about framing the issues
of UAP
hello and welcome back from lunch
everybody and uh welcome to those of you
watching us virtually I'm Nadia I am a
Scientist by training I'm also a science
journalist now and my job is to try and
synthesize the information that we've
learned so far and summarize the
situation so if you will put together a
framework for thinking about UAP
now I'm going to try and do this in a
way that reflects the thoughts of the
entire panel although obviously we have
a variety of opinions and ideas Among Us
so I'd like to leave some time at the
end for you to weigh in with
disagreements or concurrences as needed
so first a housekeeping matter the
definition of UAP changed during the
seven months of our fact-finding process
UAP initially stood for unidentified
aerial phenomena with Ariel referring to
events occurring in Earth's atmosphere
that a is now defined as anomalous which
includes the space air and undersea
domains as a panel I think we have
decided to continue focusing our
recommendations on the aerial domain
because that is where the majority of
sightings and events have occurred and
also because we couldn't fully pivot to
address the expanded scope of the new
acronym
beyond that there are three points I
want to make the first is that for a
number of reasons UAP are obviously
quite interesting right that is why we
are here
recently many credible Witnesses have
reported seeing unidentified objects in
the sky some of which are behaving
rather peculiarly peculiarly
in some instances these reports include
corroborating data from various
instruments various sensors
the challenge that we have is that the
data needed to explain these anomalous
sightings often do not exist or
incomplete for generating a conclusive
analysis
this includes eyewitness reports which
on their own can be interesting and
compelling but often lack the
information needed to make definitive
conclusions about an object's provenance
we as a panel are thinking about the
types of data that might add value to
those reports and which could be useful
on their own
as a corollary to date in the refereed
scientific literature there is no
conclusive evidence suggesting an
extraterrestrial origin for UAP
collecting more good data for the
scientific Community to review in a
peer-reviewed context will be important
for Progress to me to be made here
the second point
UAP offer an excellent opportunity to
demonstrate the power of the scientific
method and of empirically addressing a
question using a multi-disciplinary
approach
it is our job as a panel to make some
recommendations about how NASA might go
about tackling this topic scientifically
taking advantage of the agency's
resources Global Outreach and reputation
key points to keep in mind here
are that science is science is
hypothesis driven
scientists build confidence in their
theories by relying on well-calibrated
well-collected data using
well-established methods with rigorous
evaluation and independent corroboration
in science skepticism is not a bias nor
is it a bad word
it is not our job to Define nature but
to study it in ways that let nature
reveal itself to us regardless of how
exciting or disappointing that reality
might be
and to that end when we're thinking
about making recommendations about how
NASA can tackle this topic
scientifically I think it's important to
remember that it's not NASA's job to
replicate the efforts of the Department
of Defense but rather to consider
approaches that are complementary to
what the all domain anomaly resolution
office is doing
and so one of the questions that we as a
panel I think need to Center is what can
we recommend that NASA can do that the
dod cannot
third point to that end what are we even
looking for how are we defining this
problem
and how do the available data Define
what seems to be to borrow a cliche a
very slender needle in a very big
haystack
we heard a little bit about that today
from Dr Kirkpatrick who reported that
there have been 800 events
collected over about 27 years
and between two and five percent of
those events display signatures that
could be anomalous defined as anything
that is not readily understandable by
the operator or the sensor something
that is doing something weird
Mr free and some of the experts on our
panel have defined the background on
which those events exist the amount of
stuff in the sky at any given time like
so
on average FAA air traffic control
handles 45 000 flights per day in U.S
airspace with 5400 aircraft in the sky
at Peak time
worldwide on average there are about
1600 weather balloon launches per day
in the U.S there are at least 184 of
those balloons launched and that doesn't
include private companies or research
flights
there are about 1.69 million
recreational or model small uncrewed
aircraft systems
and an additional 880 000 drones are
registered for commercial use
and these are not controlled by air
traffic control and they are not
scheduled flights
so that's our challenge
so when making recommendations as a
panel I think we need to look at what
kind of imprint we want to leave what
does the situation look like five years
from now what does it look like 10 years
from now
why are we making these recommendations
we heard a little bit about this this
morning from both Mike and David who
noted that many discoveries in science
are rooted in initially unexplained and
bizarre phenomena
so by carefully scrutinizing the sky or
however we end up defining our search
space and by collaborating across
disciplines we are likely to learn new
things about our planet that's a fact
and that's the commensal science case we
might want to consider when making
recommendations here
all right
does anyone have thoughts questions
thoughts comments
Carlin
I guess I want to challenge a little bit
um
anything beyond the aerial for this
panel and and so I've just raised that
as a question for us even though mostly
what we've seen and I think Nations
NASA's mission space will be more of the
aerial
I agree with you and I think that is a
parameter that we need to Define as a
panel
yeah I'll just uh quickly jump in and
Echo some remarks I made this morning
that yes the a change from aerial to
anomalous but it's also accurate to say
that the preponderance for events
are in the aerial domain that being said
your panel scope has expanded outwards
and I think we'll hear a little bit um
from David later on that very subject
I mean I think anomalous
people often think about it as going
down and including ocean but I think
what's very relevant for NASA is going
out right and you know looking at things
in our solar system
and I think in some sense
um I think there's certain
responsibilities in you know we look at
airspace there's FAA responsibilities
there's DOD responsibilities as you get
further and further away from the Earth
eventually it's all NASA
once you get out you know towards the
you know most certainly much of the
solar system and out uh to our galaxy
that's all NASA and uh when we start you
know thinking about things like uh you
know and this will be you know David
will get to this observations beyond the
Earth's atmosphere I think this change
in language lets us also think about uh
out you know further out
in the solar system as well
good yeah
other thoughts
great did I summarize everything totally
accurately awesome
hello
all right
all right thank you
so I thought that was the perfect intro
and segue by Dr Drake for addressing why
NASA uh what what is or what are NASA's
roles in UAP studies so NASA primarily
is a science-driven agency
committed to exploring and understanding
air and space and this includes as we
were just discussing the unknown right
whether that's the farthest reaches of
the universe or right here on our home
planet
in that light NASA has over 60 years of
experience measuring phenomena in air in
space in space and air that might be
Aeronautics astronomy
as well as measuring other Earth
phenomena and this may include aquatic
or atmospheric phenomena as well and
they do this using the unique vantage
point of space
NASA's Mission data and Technical
expertise in science and engineering
may also help investigate and understand
any of the reported phenomena
it makes sense to explore what new
observations or measurements or studies
might contribute to the understanding of
reported phenomena
in that light Dr Fox made this point
this morning there's a tremendous
Archive of NASA data these are from
satellites and other space-based and
ground networks as well as other assets
and these are freely and openly
available to the public
NASA research as was mentioned also
supports a wide range of methods
this includes Advanced Data analysis
modeling Cutting Edge computational and
data visualization tools and these are
all useful for investigating unexplained
observations
which may be crucial in studying these
phenomena
discoveries and results are all publicly
available
and this can be something from the
characterization of extraterrestrial
solar planets or the whole in the ozone
layer
and these are communicated publicly
through many outlets through the agency
NASA also has a long-standing public
Trust
this is essential to communicate those
findings about phenomena to the public
and as was mentioned several times very
important to destigmatize
the reporting and raise awareness of
cultural and social barriers to doing so
NASA has a unique strength in leveraging
public and private Partnerships that
could result in new technologies that
may be useful in observing and
understanding reported phenomena
these Partners could include other
federal agencies we've heard from the
FAA today as well as NOAA was identified
and they may collect data that could
help to understand reported phenomena
in addition
NASA has a strong
record of international collaboration
which could be beneficial
to study any of these phenomena as that
may require Global cooperation and data
sharing
and then
one thing that really strikes me is that
new
understanding of anomalous events really
comes from when we bring communities
together interdisciplinary communities
that would not necessarily collaborate
um and in in my world that might be
biological and physical oceanographers
and I tell people to think a little more
broadly what if we brought together
astronomers and earth scientists like we
did on this panel
so
um that those interdisciplinary research
teams as well as citizen scientists
could explore historical and current
NASA and partner data for events or more
importantly for environmental conditions
around the time of reported events this
may help in our understanding
and then finally given NASA's experience
with long-term missions long-term
projects and scientific Focus the agency
is really well equipped to handle the
extensive and ongoing study of phenomena
investigation that this likely requires
so hopefully that gave you some thoughts
as to why NASA I don't know if any of my
fellow panelists agree or disagree
discuss
yes Paula thank you so NASA has a great
visibility in the community and not and
uaps are obviously of great interest to
a very diverse range of people so can
you speak a bit about the opportunity
that this provides for NASA to expand
um you know the knowledge of the
understanding of the scientific method
yes
um so it's a great question uh there are
multiple opportunities I think UAP
present
um the first as I mentioned I think is
to bring together interdisciplinary
research teams and scientists and
citizen scientists to really take a look
at with an objective and perhaps unique
eye
what the NASA data archive actually
means blend in the Partnerships A
Renewed partnership that's at the
federal the international and the
private level right so I think there are
any number of Pathways that people could
pursue that could be really advantageous
for helping us to understand what's
happening with any reported UAP
the questions
thank you Paula this is Charlie Wright
um actually my question and comment
actually goes to both uh you and Nadia
uh Dr Kirkpatrick gave us a definition
of anomalous that was that it was not
readily understandable to the operator
or the sensor
and from the NASA's perspective I'm for
our panel I think we have to consider a
broader definition if we're talking
about citizen science and I'm curious of
how we incorporate that especially
within the communication avenues that we
were just discussing
it's a good question
um so
um
not all data in an archive are user
friendly right right out of the the gate
but uh I think NASA does an excellent
job making things like quick look or
browse products available you can go on
the NASA website you can look at
different aspects of different things
that the agency has in its mission to
study and I think if nothing else people
have become a lot more in touch with
their surroundings and their environment
and the changes happening there and so I
think there's probably an opportunity
for people to maybe not become overnight
experts in how to process satellite data
and use it for basic research in a
complex fashion but there are ways to
utilize those data to look at your
environment if you think you've you know
seen something or you wish to report
something so communication engagement in
the public I think is a really important
part of the destigmatization for sure
Nadia I don't know if you have anything
to add
um I was I was struck by the phrase not
readily understandable I felt like that
was actually doing a lot of work
um so I think for our purposes we
probably want to come up with a slightly
more specific definition of what
anomalous actually means yes yeah
okay good thanks pederica we're up next
hello everybody my name is Federica
Bianco I am an astrophysicist and a data
scientist and I bring this perspective
to the panel so for the next few minutes
I want to emphasize some of the things
that my colleagues have already
mentioned about the data particularly
the status of the data that exist and
what the data that we should collect to
really understand what maybe
um
we've already heard in a few cases by a
few people that NASA's role is to
explore the universe through the
scientific method the application of the
scientific method to Discovery requires
that the data meets some standards that
allow the data-driven approach and there
are many standards that have been
established in the scientific community
over the years I can mention one for
example it's called a fair standard
where Fair stands for findability
accessibility
interoperability and reusability
the current status of the of the data
about uaps does not meet these standards
the data collection is inconsistent it's
in homogeneous it's uncalibrated the
data are poorly documented and largely
incomplete
um they're also not systematically
retrievable which causes a problem in
automation of the analysis
so web could benefit from data science
and machine learning methods from
artificial intelligence that is
developing at a rapid Pace but machine
learning and AI cannot be applied until
the data mean these standards even to
study a single event currently requires
a significant lift in retrieving the
data and the metadata that may or may
not be available and this lift is at the
moment entirely personal power which
means that it cannot be automated to
apply machine learning methods
organized repositories need to exist to
enable the automation of retrieval of
the data and the metadata and this is a
necessary premise to enable the
systematic scientific approach to the
study of uuaps
anomaly detection is a well-developed
although notoriously hard discipline and
which has seen tremendous advances
recently with data science and machine
learning
usually this means detecting rare and
unusual signals in a complex that is
noisy and Rich with phenomena that we
know
so there are two general approaches to
anomaly detection in the scientific
community
one is the following if we know the
signal that we expect we can model it
and we can simulate it and maybe inject
it in our data so we can develop methods
that are specific to finding those exact
signals or signals that are similar to
those
and we might be able to conceptualize
signals coming from physical system that
responds to the laws of physics as we
know them but we cannot comprehensively
produce all possible signals that could
relate to or explain new APS so the
alternative approach in detecting
anomalies requires a thorough and deep
understanding of what is normal and
usual to tease out what is unusual and
unlike the rest
these methods typically found in the
realm of what we call unsupervised
machine learning
uh
what is usual maybe the balloons the
aircrafts and what a wealth of natural
phenomena that we have heard of and what
is unusual what is an anomaly means
anything in there is not consistent with
the way in which those things look in
our data
once the enormous signal is detected it
can be studied in more depth either
through the discovery data itself but
that may not be sufficient so then we
may need to collect additional data for
to study these on these anomalies and
this is something that in astrophysics
we typically refer to as follow-up data
this can be very hard especially if the
phenomena there are anomals are also
ephemeral in time so you have to
promptly respond to the detection and
set up follow-up observations it's an
extremely hard game but it's something
that is seeing a large developing in
astrophysics in recent years with the
study of anomalous detections in the
universe
this approach relies entirely on a
comprehensive and systematic
organization of the data which is
Paramount and on a deep understanding of
all the data that is actually usual and
known
want to collect ideally will be
collected in a multi-sensor and
multi-platform and multi-site manner
eyewitnesses reports I want to elevate
what Dr Drake said cannot a certain the
nature of uaps however they should be
considered because they may contain
important information for example
persistent cycling locations or
seasonality but they only really work if
joined with quantitative data collected
by sensors as well as biophysical and
psychophysical assessments of the
witness and the impact that the
experience has on them to really reveal
the nature of uaps
um
you've heard it from them from my
colleagues a number of times the data
needs to be collected by sensors that
need to be calibrated or calibrated ball
so we need to collect not only the data
images sound spectral characterization
of what we see but metadata the sensor
type the brand the brand of the sensor
the noise characteristics time of the
acquisition instrument sensitivity as
well as information about the
circumstances of the data collection for
example temperature or the location or
the conditions in which the sensor is at
the time of collecting the data the data
should be collected simultaneously by
different platforms ideally ideally in
different location in a multi-sensor
system so some of the data that we may
want to collect are images but also
temperature sound recording spectral
data emissivity that tells you the color
in a very fine grid as well as other as
well as monitoring the motion of objects
which has been very important to
identify what we have seen as uaps that
have been reported
much of this certainly can be achieved
with professional grade infrastructure
and both new and existing infrastructure
to do that such as astrophysical and
geographical observatories both on the
ground and satellites some Modern
observatories in particular are designed
for the detection of time anomalies
specifically as well as for the
detection of objects that move rapidly
in space near Earth objects asteroids
meteors Etc so those could be leveraged
for the study of uaps
there is also some effort in ongoing in
the developing of facilities that are
specifically to detect designed to
detect uaps and many of those comply
with the characteristics that I just
described
this level of information though can
also be obtained by the public we could
crowdsource the data collection if a
platform to crowdsource exists that
supports the collection of data and
metadata and the transmission of data
and metadata and we think that NASA
might be able to play an important role
in the development of this platform
[Music]
said NASA has a wealth of experience in
coordinating scientific studies efforts
across discipline and domains serving as
a bridge between communities in the
interdisciplinary studies and studies
across different countries
all of these can be supported all of
these can be leveraged to support the
work of the other agencies in the
identification and explaining explaining
uaps NASA also has a really important
experience in data curation we have
heard about the sophistication of the
analysis of the data that NASA provides
of the sophistication of the calibration
that the data that NASA shares
arrives to we have heard about the open
data policy that NASA data goes under
has recently spearheaded an effort to
review NASA and as a partner archival
data to prepare them for machine
learning and AI so that data can be
served to the community directly and
ready to apply AI methods on it this is
an important experience that could be
leveraged in the study of uaps however
we do want to emphasize that the current
status of the UAP data will make this
list really hard compared to even what
is being done by NASA for astrophysical
data
and finally I wanted to emphasize what
my colleague said NASA has a great
visibility UAP is ever out of great
power of great public interest and this
could be an opportunity to really
increase the reach of science help
people understand the scientific process
and maybe diversify the scientific
Community by attracting new Talent into
the scientific Community due to the
visibility of the problem
and I think that's all of my remarks
questions
you want to go Reggie
so uh on the whole crowdsourcing front
and getting uh reports from citizen
scientists uh what do you think along
those lines is it uh providing a set of
guidelines for how you report is it open
sourcing a set of applications for cell
phones to be able to pull in a lot the
right metadata uh what does that look
like yeah so um I think guidance would
necessaril guidance
best practices Etc would just now be
sufficient
what needs to be provided is a platform
you mentioned cell phones cell phones
have been used for
crowdsourcing the study and detection of
a number of things in astrophysics in
space science so that can definitely be
done the issue I think is going to be to
make sure that this platform is
um that this platform reaches a large
enough Community to really have a crowd
to Source the problem and coordination
something that this could achieve for
example is uh the follow-up that I
mentioned earlier right so we need this
community that would use
um the crowdsourcing facilities to be
connected so that if something is cited
by one person that message can go across
and a broader Community can point their
sensors to the problem
to the sighting and the data has to be
transmitted to that has to be
transmitted to a place that can
centralize it and curate it
yeah please feel free to say this is a
bad idea but if you thought about
synthetic data as you were talking I was
thinking you know given the fact we
don't have enough quality data to
training a net a neural net if we're to
generate synthetic data based on the
information we do have and then filling
out the other characteristics as we
might guess because that that help us
train something to iterate an AI to be
to find other correlations within data
as we get it so
cars and we
should learning models it's a risky
business because in the data that we
generate we embed the bias that we have
so we invite are thinking about the data
the way in which we think the data looks
and the way in which we think the
anomalies look so particularly in
anomaly detection it is a very difficult
thing to do
to try to make sure that you don't bias
your models to what you know I want to
come back to this topic of anomaly
discussion in our general discussion
we're sort of starting to run a little
late so I want to cut off questions now
but we do have a little time later at
the end so don't forget don't forget
your questions bring them up again in
discussion and we'll we'll talk more
more later
great so uh David's our next speaker
all right good afternoon my name is
David grinspoon I'm a planetary
scientist and astrobiologist and I'm
going to talk for uh just a couple of
minutes about how observations beyond
Earth are relevant to
um our uh study of uaps
um
many of NASA's missions are at least in
part focused on answering the question
of whether life exists beyond Earth
astrobiology is the study of the origin
Evolution distribution and future of
life in the universe
as part of this we consider how to
search for biosignatures observations we
can make of other planets which may
might betray the presence of life so we
look for things like anomalous gases in
the atmospheres of planets and other
anomalies which may possibly reveal the
presence of life when we discover such
an anomaly we don't
conclude that we've discovered life we
seek more data to understand what we're
seeing and often this leads to other new
discoveries
similarly we can talk about looking for
techno signatures observations we can
make which might reveal the presence of
technological activity somewhere else
NASA is also supporting signatures
while there is a present no evidence
we're aware of suggesting an
extraterrestrial source for uaps these
existing NASA programs are relevant to
the question of uaps in at least two
ways
first
researchers in astrobiology and seti the
search for extraterrestrial intelligence
have focused for many years on
techniques and methods for identifying
anomalous signatures and determining if
they have mundane natural explanations
as opposed to revealing unknown
biological or even technological
activity
the City Community has expertise and
methodologies for determining whether a
potential techno signature is in fact a
natural phenomenon or misinterpreted
terrestrial technology
when a possible techno signature is
observed we asked is it a real signal
is it
a known or unknown natural phenomena
must it be technological
uh is it known terrestrial technology
so these scientific communities have
relevant experience in determining and
communicating about weather observations
which first appeared to reveal
extraordinary evidence actually justify
making extraordinary claims
second
if we do acknowledge an extraterrestrial
Source however unlikely as one
possibility for uaps then these objects
must have traveled through the solar
system to get here
Within the scientific Community there's
a widespread but by no means Universal
belief that there are extraterrestrial
civilizations and we have a
well-developed rationale there's a lot
of literature for discussing this which
I won't go into now uh in the interest
of brevity but it has to do with the
vast numbers of exoplanets and the time
scales of evolution and the possibility
of convergent evolution on different
planets leading to somewhat similar
outcomes it's a fascinating subject but
uh the the relevant Point here is that
the same rationale which support
supports the idea the extra
extraterrestrial civilizations may exist
and may be detectable also supports the
idea that finding extraterrestrial
artifacts in our own solar system is at
least plausible
NASA is the lead Agency for solar system
exploration
it already has an active program of
detecting objects in our Solar
neighborhood using both ground-based and
space-based facilities and it could
leverage those capabilities to search
for objects in space with anomalous
motion
anomalous trajectories
unusual light curves anomalous spectral
signatures or other characteristics
most of the solar system has not been
searched for artifacts or anomalies and
these modest data analysis efforts could
potentially be applied to existing and
planned planetary missions
the Galaxy does not stop at the edge of
the solar system and the solar system
does not stop at the top of the Earth's
atmosphere it's all a Continuum of
possibilities worthy of Investigation
if NASA applies the same rigorous
methodology toward uaps that it applies
to the study of possible life elsewhere
than we stand to learn something new and
interesting whatever the ultimate
explanation is of those phenomena
and that's all I wanted to say right now
now we have time for uh one or two
comments or questions or thoughts
yeah
um thank you for that you know it struck
me while you were speaking
um about bio signatures that we do a lot
of that type of analysis right and our
home planet in in different capacities
and so it's more of a comment but I
wondered your thoughts on you know
bringing together those communities that
might not work together and whether that
would Aid in you know not only
establishing what's normal but you know
enabling the detection or maybe the
understanding explanation of a UAP if
reported absolutely I mean uh you know
the focus of my talk was was
observations elsewhere but in fact most
of what the field of astrobiology has to
study is here on Earth because after all
it's our one example of an inhabited
planet and it's a little bit easier to
get to to make observations so yes uh
any any insights do you have uh in that
area or any any suggestions for uh for
uh collaboration between those
communities uh would be very valuable
so of course NASA hasn't been
researching the Techno signature field
for very long and there's been a stigma
with techno signatures for many decades
are there any Lessons Learned
we can impose from the Techno signature
in the study Community to the UAP and
solar system studies
that's a really
good question
um
I guess the the immediate thought it
Sparks in me is that um
yeah techno signatures
were kind of treated uh at kept at arm's
length for a long time by NASA because
of stigma
and ultimately uh
can't be kept
away forever if you're if you are an
agency curiosity driven trying to
understand the whole universe you have
to move Beyond stigmas and just try to
honestly look at whatever evidence there
is and so I think in that broad sense
the same lesson Otto apply to uaps
um so someone who has been working in
astrobiology and data Sciences for some
time now it strikes me when both Dr
Bianco and you talked that the
differences that seem to me between
biosignatures and techno signatures
fields and UAP field again relies on the
data so biosignatures and techno
signatures they have are very well
standardized data sets they have collect
been collecting data sets for some time
and they are able to apply machine
learning artificial intelligence
algorithms while it's a totally
different question with uaps in how we
can apply artificial intelligence here
so again just like Dr Bianca how she
said it's about data standardization so
I hope that the UAP field will learn how
to work with the data from the
biosignatures and techno signatures
fields
yeah that's a good point the one the one
uh point I pushed back on a little bit
is whether techno signatures has been
has a lot of data in that sense the the
one part of techno signatures which is
looking for signals from radio and
Optical and that sort of thing that's
been you know associated with seti for a
long time you're right there's a lot of
data there that we've been collecting
but the term techno signature is this
sort of newly being adopted in it uh in
a way it reminds me of the distinction
we heard um from the FAA about a
cooperative and you know non-cooperative
uh that with techno signatures we're
looking
um there's more of an emphasis on
finding
um technology that is not necessarily
intended to Signal us but just sort of
uh doing what technology does and
finding ways to you know so it's not
looking for signals as much and in that
domain we have not necessarily been
collecting information for that long but
but your point is well taken that there
are lessons learned from uh certainly
the astrobiology and the the sort of
classical seti field where we've had a
lot of data and we could look at how
that is analyzed and try to collect the
data for uaps that will be amenable to
that same sort of analysis
great thank you uh Carlin's next
hello everybody I'm Carlin toner a mon
aerospace engineer
you know it really struck me when Dr
Drake opened up this afternoon and
talked about this really small needle in
a really big Haystack that we're looking
for and I'm going to talk to you about
reporting a theme that we've heard a lot
how can we make that Haystack smaller
and that needle bigger
so reporting of uip events has received
a lot of attention recently but I think
that there are still barriers for people
to report
how or where should they report
will someone take action on their report
will the reporter be believed or will
they be shamed
we've heard over the course of our fact
finding that many scientists and
aviators consider the study of uaps to
be Fringe at best
so this suggests there's a significant
negative stigma associated with
reporting or even researching such
phenomena
that said by encouraging military
aviators to disclose anomalies that
they've seen or detected the Department
of Defense is receiving many more
reports I think in the time that we've
been looking at this topic growing from
an ODI report that was something like
500 to I think this morning we heard
something like 800 now so that's
accelerating
and a DOD will soon also mandate if not
already reporting by pilots which we
even grow that set
I would propose to this panel that NASA
can help make it safer for researchers
to explore data in the Civil airspace
domain
simply by starting that work internally
NASA could look at how civil anomaly
data is shared
study how to incentivize reporting
assess the possibility of crowdsourcing
data which I think we've heard a bit
about this afternoon
we're sponsor and participate in
conferences on UAP detection
our team has really only seen I'd say a
few unclassified images of UAP
which lack the contextual data that's
needed to understand their true nature
and I believe we've heard a single
first-hand account from a former
military Aviator
so one of my colleagues Josh has an
example
to show just why it would be important
for NASA to also help shape how the data
and information is reported
but before I turn the mic over to Josh I
want to make a recommendation to my
fellow panelists that we consider
advising NASA to more fully assess the
cultural and social barriers to studying
and Reporting UAP
and for NASA to implement a plan to
leverage its brand image to start
removing these obstacles
but
you just want to go up and then we'll
we'll take discussion
so you can call it my slide deck if you
want
so it's not it's not the charge of our
panel to evaluate UAP evidence but part
of our statement of task is to assess
the scientific analysis techniques that
are available you don't have to start it
just yet and the um
and how we might use them to determine
physical constraints on UAP
you know the UAP reports with the most
detailed contextual informations are the
ones from the Navy aviators and they're
using a combination of of ranging and uh
infrared Imaging information and for
these cases we can directly calculate
critical parameters of a UAP such as
altitude and velocity under certain
assumptions and it's you know the main
point I want to make here is that this
multi-sensor approach is absolutely
critical to charting a path forward for
UAP investigations and that pertains to
NASA as well so I'm going to provide one
example here just to illustrate the
crucial role of Science and scientific
analysis
and
the role of scientific analysis to avoid
misinterpretation in some sense next
build
hit space
yeah okay so this is um
this video was recorded by
um Pilots deployed from the aircraft
carrier USS Theodore Roosevelt in 2015.
the example has been given the nickname
go fast because it gives an impression
of an object moving very rapidly against
the ocean's surface and uh you know the
question is is this impression correct
and uh you know if not what can we say
quantitatively about what that object is
doing in uh kind of earth-centered
coordinate system
fortunately the information needed to
determine the altitude and velocity of
this object is contained on the display
so go ahead and
next
and uh
this includes the elevation angle of the
camera
um the Azimuth angle of the camera the
target range in nautical miles aircraft
altitude the time reference and set
air speed and Knots you know this
information in this video in particular
has been discussed quite a bit on the on
the web
so let's begin with the object altitude
next please
so knowing the Jet's altitude and the
bearing to the Target we can apply basic
trigonometry to figure out where that
object is in altitude space and it's
turns out to be you know provided the
range information is accurate which can
have some uncertainties associated with
it but the object appears to be at about
13 000 feet an important aspect of this
here is that it's sort of midway between
the uh the jet and the ocean so it's the
ocean that looks like it's right behind
it is actually 4.2 miles away and this
is our first indication that some or
most of the motion that we observe the
apparent motion of the object
is in fact due to the rapid motion of
the sensing platform which is about 430
miles per hour in this case
uh
but we don't have to guess about this so
we have enough information on this
display to actually reconstruct
the encounter go to the next slide
please
and uh so this is what this is this is
using additional information on the
screen including the time axis and um so
we know that this aircraft is banking
about 15 degrees left and you can
compute through a simple calculator the
radius approximate radius of curvature
of the flight and you the bottom line is
I won't go into detail here but if you
can get the bearing and range to the
Target at two locations with known
separation in time you can figure out
how far it moved and in this case this
object moved about 390 meters
um in 22 seconds and that corresponds to
a velocity of just 40 miles per hour
and so that's a velocity it's consistent
with wind speeds at 13 000 feet
so it's not our task to conjecture what
this object is but it's an example that
illustrates the type of data needed to
determine critical parameters that will
help us identify such objects going
forward
in addition to the importance of
quantitative analysis this example also
serves to illustrate the kind of
cognitive bias we have to contend with
for uaps recorded from unfamiliar
perspectives and uh Sean Kirkpatrick
showed another example of that this is
uh this is a parallax effect case
foreign
thank you
any questions thanks
um actually before we have questions
actually a good moment uh Sean and I
wanted to comment on his
one of the questions if we bring Sean up
and then take questions for everybody on
more discussion
thanks that was that was actually very
helpful for everyone I'm sure
just one piece of clarification on the
video that we showed the second one that
was the new
newly released one had the three
aircraft in it the question was asked
about if it was a stabilized background
against which the Jitter was showing I I
am not 100 certain of that answer it
might just be a bunch of dust on that
sensor but let me go back and get you a
more Folsom answer is either stabilized
background or it's just garbage but in
either event the three aircraft are
um jittering because of the platform but
that's another example of exactly what
you're saying right it's the perception
of the of the operator who thinks it's
doing something else when it's actually
just your own camera
yes I can just Sean in your event it
seemed to me that what you mean by
Jitter in this case is the the plane is
actually making motions that are causing
a parallax so it's actually more than
that uh so the plane will move and
that'll cause The Parallax that you just
showed
but the sensor itself the a lot of these
cameras are in gimbals for those of you
not certain what a gimbal is it's the
thing that your your cameras sit on your
telescopes sit on it moves it around in
different directions
those can sometimes be stabilized in
which case they
they uh damp out the motion of the
platform
and in other cases they're not and they
they jump around and so what you're
actually seeing in that video is what we
call Jitter of the sensor against the
platform so the platform's moving and
the sensor is moving it's not a
stabilized against the target but the
once it's collected sometimes in
processing the background is stabilized
frame to frame just like some of those
Tick Tock videos you see right same idea
yeah I just wanted to jump in here I
think uh make a couple of comments so
just follow up on what uh Josh said in
my experience of flying you know over 15
000 hours 30 something years in
airplanes and and both in space
and the environment that we fly in space
or you know an atmospheric flight very
very conducive to optical illusions so I
get it why these Pilots would look at
that go fast video and think it was
going really really fast
um I remember one time I was flying in
the warning areas off of Virginia Beach
Military operating area there and my Rio
thought the guy that sits in the back of
the Tomcat was convinced we flew by a
UFO
so I didn't see it we turned around we
went to go look at it it turns out it
was Bart Simpson a balloon
you know oftentimes in space I would see
things and I was like oh that's really
not behaving like it should it's not it
doesn't have a trajectory of a satellite
or a planet on the back of the star
field and every single time when I would
look at it long enough I would realize
that it was atmospheric lensing it was
the fact that what I was looking at was
actually flying behind the atmosphere
and because of variations in the
atmosphere it made the trajectory look
like it wasn't going in a straight line
it was going like this and it would go
like that and it would turn in the other
direction always was always the case
my brother uh Mark Kelly a former NASA
astronaut and also now a U.S senator I
was with him for dinner last night and
he shared a story
with me again that he had shared years
ago but I had kind of forgotten about it
and I think it's worth sharing and that
that is when he was the commander of SDS
124 I think it was in 2008. they were
getting ready to close the payload bay
doors of the Space Shuttle
and before they do that you got to make
sure nothing interferes with the doors
because if the doors don't close
properly the space shuttle can't
re-enter the atmosphere it would come
apart it's part of the structural
Integrity of the vehicle so they see
something in the payload Bay and they
thought it was a tool maybe a bolt they
couldn't quite figure it out they were
potentially going to have to go and do a
spacewalk to retrieve it
but before they did that my brother
grabbed the camera they took a picture
of it and when they blew up the picture
they realized that this is not a bolt or
a tool in the payload Bay it was
actually the International Space Station
that was 80 miles away
I mean that's just a really good example
of how this environment we operate in is
so so conducive optical illusions
oftentimes guys fly into the water I
mean there are cases where you know
Pilots have rendezvoused on a buoy
because they thought that was their
wingman it's just very very
challenging environment to work and
especially at night and
in my experience the sensors kind of
have the same issues as the you know the
people's eyeballs
so per what Scott just said I think we
need to take it as an action to
investigate unidentified animated
phenomena to go after art Simpson I I
think what Josh and Scott said is very
very helpful and shows why we need
multiple sources of data
were their radar hits were there other
sightings unless we can look at this
from a holistic perspective it's very
difficult to draw conclusions and
relative to stigma I appreciate the
reports that our colleagues gave I think
there's plenty of stigma right here in
this building and I'm sure Dan you've
suffered from it at times
and I just want to commend administrator
although who's always be Senator Nelson
to me for his leadership and candidly
courage and getting an asset to tackle
this issue
and as we look at what Sean had
articulated that what he wants NASA to
do as we look at the recommendations for
reporting and how we need to collate
that reporting I'm very concerned that
this could be effectively done on an ad
hoc basis and I've been a part of far
too many panels and studies that end up
sitting on the shelf I don't want this
to be one of those exercises and we can
discuss this further but I would call
for and recommend a permanent office
within NASA to support this activity
albeit likely a modest one but to
collate this information collate that
data to Archive the information and act
as the open forward-facing counterpart
to Sean and aaro I think then we could
continue and actually accomplish the
reporting the stigma issues that have
been raised and we could do so in a
relatively affordable fashion because
again I don't want all of our work to
end up being in vain
so now
Jen's going to turn to our charge
and
and you know as a panel we were convened
with a set of questions that we were
charged to address we've been
addressing them through the topics we've
talked about and through things as we've
been thinking this through but we're
going to organize the next part of the
discussion with Jen presenting these
things and this is also a chance to get
into some of the discussion phase
because we can look at each of these
questions as the topics that we make we
want to make sure we address as part of
the report Jen
thanks David and I want to thank the
panelists all for all of your work all
of the knowledge that I've gained from
from each of you through this time I
took it upon myself in preparing for
today's meeting to draft a statement
that answers the eight questions that we
were provided at the beginning of the
uh last summer when the the panel was
was created so I'm going to read the
question out loud I'm going to read my
statement and I'm going to pause and let
you think and reflect and if there's
remember this isn't all of the details
associated with each of these answers
right this is to be a kind of high level
make sure we've got the major points
there
um and and this is an initial take for
for these answers
so the first question goes what types of
scientific data currently collected and
archived by NASA or other civilian
government entities should be
synthesized and analyzed prior to
potentially shed light on the nature and
origins of UAP
so the panel reviewed data sources
analytic tools data architectures from
NASA NOAA FAA Commerce and others
the data that we recognize were not
collected for the purpose of identifying
UAP
which leaves bias in the data that was
collected even though there is an
immense amount of data available it is
hard to access and the sensors that were
used were not well calibrated for
identifying anomalous phenomena
no questions moving forward question
number two I kind of feel like Jeopardy
what what types of scientific data
currently collected and held by
non-profits and companies should be
synthesized and analyzed to potentially
shed light on the nature and origins of
UAP
many organizations exist to track
sightings of anomalous phenomena in the
Earth's atmosphere
both non-profit for-profit and otherwise
the study panel concluded that much of
the inputs collected by these
organizations are not considered
scientific data in nature and that they
do not contain unbiased information
they're not repeatable and they
typically come with eyewitness accounts
which we've heard even today that
there's a hesitations with using only
eyewitness accounts to recognize or
identify UAP
um to the point about commercial or
companies there are a lot of space
companies that some lobbied hard to get
in to present to us they have trolls of
data but they're collected for a variety
of different purposes than the purpose
of UAP and those systems while they are
well calibrated are only one source of
many that could be used
um and questions comments concerns yes
Carlin I'll bite on that one Jen
um
you know I I think your answer is
correct as to what we've seen but where
I would go is if we made a
recommendation to NASA that you know
we're really asking them to build a road
map and we haven't done a robust catalog
and we've looked at sources mentioned
sources that we think might be relevant
but perhaps a more robust effort
cataloging would be a good modest start
yeah
that's good I I will only in slight
defense of trying to answer the exact
question as opposed to the panel rather
than trying to add recommendations at
this point but yes point will take it
and thank you
I mean I think one of the data sets that
we just learned about you know heard
more about today and thinking about sort
of calibrating things is the FAA data on
a normal on you know tracking events
right and I think this is something
where if we had you know
some imaging software people you know
sell citizen scientists with cell phone
cameras Identify some event that looks
interesting one of the places you'd like
to be able to turn is the FAA data and
having
um you know if there is to go back to
you know having a NASA
responsibility for data and NASA might
you know
has a lot of experience in serving as a
clearing house for data from across the
government for civilian data right this
is something we do in lots of different
areas and I I think there are some
opportunities with data sets there and I
think the the radar data is one that
comes to mind is one we don't want to
forget about as an available data set
yeah absolutely
um question three I think goes more
towards the recommendations of what
other types of scientific data should be
collected by NASA to enhance the
potential for developing an
understanding of the nature and origins
of UAP so we've heard now from two of
the panelists on some of the information
that should be collected or the way that
some of that data should be organized in
a manner to make it available for people
to analyze that information
and the only other thoughts that I had
here was was really recognizing the
difference in
um the sensor thresholds right so we
can't always tune a sensor all the way
to the resolution that we might need or
we might want and and as we collect that
data to recognize for the scientists
that are doing those analyzes to the
bounds of each of the systems that
they're that they're using
yeah
what strikes me on that one when you
were reading the the answer the proposed
answer was
um
what may be new maybe something that's
new to NASA in the sense of like a Time
series so we can know what's normal so
we can perhaps identify what's not
normal or anomalous right
so I'm not sure to what extent
um it's like the most unsexy thing to
sell on the face of the planet right is
making consistent long-term observations
but I think that the agency may be set
up to do just that for multiple reasons
right yeah persistent yeah data
collection the agency does that in a lot
of cases for us through physical
purposes so the infrastructure of course
you know pointing up and pointing at a
different distance but the
infrastructure for collecting this kind
of data organizing and keeping it and
that does exist yeah and there are
in their defense a lot of satellite
companies that are doing that persistent
collection as well
question for which scientific analysis
techniques currently in production could
be employed to assess the nature and
origins of UAP which types of analysis
techniques should be developed this is a
two-part with what exists today and what
should be so we're looking also at
recommendations
based on the information provided by the
presenters to the panel there are very
few credible analysis technique
techniques available
that currently exist
to assess the nature and origins of UAP
the onset of artificial intelligence and
automated analysis techniques give
promise to being able to do that in the
future
um I wanted to add something to that
perhaps which is that really to design
the analysis you need to know what the
data looks like right so
um you know we can't really say what
kind of analysis should be created on
the hypothetical data that we're
recommending should be collected in a in
a in some you know somewhat specified
fashion if it's all hypothetical and we
want to collect all of this data and we
know what format it's going to be in we
can design analysis techniques around it
and at that point it's likely that there
are analysis techniques that are that
already exist absolutely also anomaly
detection work we just don't know which
one will be more suitable because the
data as it should be it doesn't exist
yet correct
you said exactly what I was going to say
yeah and that that's what I was getting
at with my point not that those analysis
techniques don't exist in the scientific
Community just that they're not being
applied to this problem set right now
and it's hard to apply them when we
don't have the the known data of what
would go into those David yeah I I think
something we want to stress here is the
importance of uniform data yes in the
way it's collected because particularly
when you're looking for outliers if you
have data coming from many different
observing techniques right and just
having a uniform set of cameras a
uniform set of detectors so you
understand and characterize them right
because this is a needle in the haystack
problem and you know every camera I mean
I'd mentioned in the uh opening session
ghosting in Optics yes now that's going
to be different in every different
detector every day right and you
um before we get to the analysis
techniques we want to make sure we
design the data collection so that the
analysis techniques can effectively be
used on it right David can I take a
slight issue with that which is
it sounds like you're implying that you
need a single way of collecting the data
I'd argue it's really you need to
understand the various ways in which
you're collecting the data and you're
able to cross-calibrate across those
different approaches
uh because I seriously doubt that there
is a single detector
I I think a handful of ways so that
you're yeah well characterized things
things need to be well characterized to
be useful I guess is the way I would
state it and uh it takes time and energy
to well characterize things so that
that's that's I think the challenge
[Music]
it's where we can actually apply
artificial intelligence so we cannot
apply Artificial Intelligence on the
current data but we can apply artificial
intelligence in a way that we can design
characteristics for the data that we
need and how we can collect the data
that we need so
and this is probably more of a
frustration than anything else so I
don't know how helpful it'll be but I
think we're not looking for a needle in
Haystack we're looking for anomaly in
Haystack we don't even know that we're
looking for a needle that it's just a
discolored piece of hay
I'm from Montana so I love good hay
analogy
I don't know what the phenomenology is
that we're looking for
we say Anonymous again this question
earlier what does that mean anomalous
acceleration like I think as we try to
look at the data we're starting from an
almost impossible position when if we
don't know what we're looking for is it
a radiation signature is it something
electromagnetic is it something like
that is why this is so challenging and
frustrating to me that we're talking
about monitoring something that we don't
even know what we're supposed to Monitor
and let me just offer Josh before you
jump in the the scientific process of
hypothesis-driven research right of that
while we don't know all of the possible
outcomes in the entire world we can ask
very specific questions and go about it
in a very scientific process to
understand so you're right we don't know
exactly what we're looking for but we
know hot spots as we've seen from both
FAA and ARL we do know some of those
conditions that we might be looking
looking for so if you start with with
kind of what you know or places to start
to go and look and you start with the
data that we have available to us
we might start being able to untangle
the chicken and egg problem
so Jen what is the phenomena that we're
looking for
so we've heard them from Sean
I would pull up Sean's chart but I can't
quickly do that
um of the criteria that he said on the
trends I use word criteria he said
trends of six or seven
um
uh phenomena I guess of specific size or
within a specific motion range and it's
something
different than what we've seen before
something we don't recognize
and so when you go to look for something
that you don't recognize
it it can be pretty easy and that we've
fooled ourselves today and even watching
some of these videos of what's going on
but when you're able to corroborate that
with three or four other sources it
starts to make sense
right so something that looks like magic
to the naked eye or to that camera in
that sensor
isn't once you understand all of the
effects of what was going on in the
surrounding environment
some kind of question can we um because
I got the same frustration you do right
it's it's regardless of um what you're
looking for if you don't know what it is
whether you're using AI or match
filtering techniques you can't find it
right you can't find it so because the
question I have is can we use social
media that kind of thing as a way of
queuing
um to know where something's happening
because we know Google searches can lead
you to better understand where outbreaks
happen right disease outbreaks can you
similar type of conflation of data to
start saying well something's going on
here let's start cueing sensors in that
area that requires some real-time
capability but is that something we can
think about
can I object to that just a bit uh you
can find things that you don't know how
they look okay there there is a lot of
the algorithms in anomaly detection are
really based on let's know let's find
out how what we know looks like so that
anything that doesn't look like that can
be identified and spotted and then we
can think whether or not we understand
you right and so I think the point about
the homogeneous detectors really is
about that we need to have a solid
understanding of the normal to detect
the abnormal through the outliers as we
sometimes perhaps more often call them
in in science right yeah absolutely I do
want to be cautious of time
we were supposed to end this about 10
minutes ago right so but this is drifted
into discussion but I think we're doing
discussion so do you have any last topic
you want to hit if not then we'll just
open up to General discussion I have
four more questions that we're
technically supposed to answer all right
let's do one
we can do four questions in two minutes
right
what basic physical constraints can be
placed on the nature and origins of UAP
Mike would you like to take this
question absolutely okay got it
um I
uh in my my notes to answer this knew
that Sean had presented some Trends so I
I used that kind of as the basis for
um what basic physical constraints could
be available
um and also the Josh's presentation that
he just presented of we know some of
these are still in the realm of
understanding we just haven't applied
basic physics to understand what's there
what we have
uh question six what civilian airspace
data related to uaps have been collected
by government agencies and are available
for analysis to a inform efforts to
better understand the nature and origins
of uaps and B determine the risk of uaps
to the National airspace
um
so
we saw some of this in I'm going to use
examples from today to kind of move
quickly
um some of this in Mike freeze
presentation and talking about the the
error risks right that FAA is always
looking out for
um
we know
um by altitude and by sensor and
curvature of the earth and line of sight
and as you get higher that you can see
more right so we have a lot of Civilian
airspace data that can start to
understand
the nature and origins of the UAP and
determining the risk
is based on how much you know right so
you think about I I go straight to space
and I think about satellites and one's
um tiny piece of space debris can
destroy an entire satellite because
they're moving really really fast in in
the vacuum of space it's not necessarily
so true in airspace right but something
that we don't know could have a severe
impact on pilots and their flight plan
and all of that which then could really
wreak havoc on all of all of the United
States airspace and so being able to
understand and identify what those are
phenomena are will help de-risk the air
flight safety
the in the National airspace
um question seven what current reporting
protocols and air traffic management
data acquisition systems can be modified
to acquire additional data on past and
future uaps we've heard a lot of the
reporting structures it was talked about
earlier today those probably can be
adapted and improved and it's up to us
in discussion as the panel on what those
recommendations might be question eight
and I'll get off stage what potential
enhancements to the Future air traffic
management development efforts can be
recommended to acquire data concerning
future reported uaps to assist in the
effort to better understand the nature
and origins of the uaps
um
the potential enhancements
automatic filtering of the knowns has
come up as a talking point
um
these are
uh specific really to acquiring data
the tuning of those sensor platforms
the multimodal Spectrum collection and
being able to kind of time stamp or
geostamp each of those to to collaborate
the the sightings so I will leave the
panel with that with time to continue
discussion
thank you
okay great let me go up to let me uh
complete destruction from there
but before I open it up I just wanted to
restate federica's answer to Mike for
hey
if you know the properties of hay very
well
and you can you go through your Haystack
and say
I don't know what this is but it doesn't
look like hey
you don't need to have a match filter
looking for a needle in a haystack if
you know hay very well
I
now as a New York City resident
impression as we go through hay with
your you don't want to do it with your
hands
but I I defer to you
on a uh yeah
I think I am yeah so um I want to
in the final minutes we have here before
the public session
look to the Future
I think a lot of us have looked at the
data we have now with a sense of
dissatisfaction
and say what data would you want and how
would you want to collect it
and just think about you know we don't
need to design the detectors but think
about the characterization that we we'd
like what wavelengths we'd like and you
know just to kind of throw that out as a
one way to think about uh
what we might want to recommend
oh
so one thing that strikes me in that
question is that I'm not totally certain
that we've dedicated our time and effort
to looking for
anomalies I think by default there are
some science communities
that look for things like
um the Genesis of a hurricane or a
harmful algal bloom in the ocean or you
know something in interstellar space but
I'm not sure we ever focused our
interdisciplinary effort on that and I
think the question you ask is a really
interesting one part of our statement of
task right but I'm not sure I can answer
that quite yet that's how I feel about
that one
Shelley Wright
um yeah going along with Dr bontempi's
point there
we heard a lot from Arrow about
specifics about the needle one to four
meters in size zero to Mach two you can
then look at NASA's assets right
and look at its spatial resolution its
spectral resolution in particular the
frame rate to get I'm going to get your
question here
um Dr spurgle
you can look at the current NASA assets
and try to say which ones could find
that needle the ones that Dr Kirkpatrick
put forward
that analysis has not been done so one
of my recommendations would be for NASA
to convene a group and a task force to
look at its current assets to calculate
what current available data current data
and current facilities could answer
insight into that now to get to your
future question looking at this I see
Walter is um frame rate I see a really
big issue with frame rate so if you want
to catch fast moving objects you need to
take quick images if you want to get to
these very small sizes and resolution
depending on altitude where your actual
you're taking your image from ground or
space
NASA will likely have to increase its
frame rate into its detectors
I think short answer to what NASA's
current assets would be able to see
would be really big Haystacks that are
moving very slowly which I think is the
point that you're making
but that doesn't mean that that data is
not useful because if it's able to
characterize the background extremely
well
that
gives you a better idea of what unusual
looks like basically anything that you
do that characterizes the background
will contribute to an understanding
so we're going to have to cut this off
now because we're now going to our our
public session public comment session so
turn that over
hello everybody
uh I am Karen Fox with NASA's office of
communications and we are segwaying into
the public q a portion of this meeting
uh as a reminder this is a facca meeting
that is a federal advisory committee act
and so we are under guidance which says
that these meetings are public and that
we take public uh questions uh we got
hundreds and hundreds of questions and I
just want to take a moment to say thank
you to everybody who who submitted them
uh we're obviously not going to get to
all of them today but we are going to
make attempts to answer some of them
online you can always check back to
science.nasa.gov UAP where over time we
will make it clear where we're putting
up some more of those answers in the
meantime we did have to make some
decisions uh we stuck two questions that
applied to this independent study and
uaps there were a lot of questions about
astrobiology and other subjects that
we're not going to get to today and also
in an attempt to get to as many of the
questions as possible since so many of
them were similar we've we've sort of
bucketed them and that is how we're
going to try to address as many as
possible so I'm going to toss the
questions to you and we'll and we'll
look to getting some answers for our for
our public questions
all right so first set of questions
um are specifically about the the data
being used so
examples what exactly are you
incorporating into your report what data
are we using what are some examples of
data being used do we have multi-sensor
data or of objects performing Maneuvers
that seem truly anomalous do we have
photos videos what about having the NASA
historian go through the NASA's
historical records did you interview
military or Pilots for this study so
looking for some information about the
kinds of data
I can toss to anyone David looks like
he's dumping it well I think first and
foremost our goal here is a way to
create a roadmap
right so really you know we have been
informed by some of the events that are
reported and we've had but we've
certainly not done a complete historical
study or art in an archive and I think
one of the things we've wanted to do was
learn what kinds of events have been
reported learn about some of the one to
minimum resolve some of the ones that
are unresolved so we can best think
about
how in the future
we can collect data so that we can get
more robust answers
so that
I hope that that addressed that question
it does
others have anything else they'd like to
add
all right
said I will keep going
uh another big question
Rory was about transparency and about
sharing information and so examples in
this category are what is NASA hiding
and where are you hiding it
how much has been shared publicly has
NASA ever cut the live NASA TV feed away
from something has NASA released all UAP
evidence it has ever received what about
NASA astronauts do they have an NDA or
clearance that does not allow them to
speak about UAP sightings
what are the science overlords hiding
Dan Evans all right I'll take a stab at
last month that one I really want to
assure the public
and to double down on some remarks I
made this morning that this agency is
absolutely cast iron committed to
openness and transparency and honesty
and that commitment also extends to our
live NASA TV feeds they provide
real-time footage from our various
missions
now to my knowledge NASA has never
intentionally cut a live feed to hide
anything and that includes uaps of
course
sometimes there are interruptions to our
feeds but that is simply because space
is a complex place there's a vast array
of natural phenomena human-made objects
and so forth but again I wanted to
reassure the public that we're
absolutely committed to providing the
public transparency and openness those
are the Hallmarks of NASA that's why
we're here today in public on TV because
we want the public to have the
opportunity to see the process of this
committee doing its work in public it's
only right
just to follow up on what I what I said
I I didn't mean to be to joke about it
but in my 20 years at Nasa no one
either officially or unofficially
in my recollection have ever discussed
or briefed us or had any kind of
discussions about anything that would be
considered a UAP or UFO or anything like
that and I'll ask you to stand for one
second and state your name I'll ask you
to stand for one second and state your
name just so everybody know who was
speaking it's hard I'm just following up
on uh on the question about if NASA
astronauts ever signed an NDA or
anything of that anything like that in
my experience of being in the astronaut
office for 20 years there was never any
formal or informal discussions at all
about uaps or UFOs or anyone reporting
anything that would suggest something
from you know beyond our planet
thank you very much yes please just want
to make a quick comment about the the
culture of Science in relation to this
question uh scientists by Nature are are
at least intellectually sort of
rebellious it's it's in our nature to
question authority you know uh uh that's
how you're a good scientist you don't
just take someone's word for it you try
to uh discover the truth and for that
reason uh you know this question about
what other science overlords hiding
that's sort of written in a facetious
way but I I just want to emphasize that
uh
but there's no way that that all
scientists could be in on on on on
trying to hide something because it's
just not in our nature if somebody told
me to try to hide something as a
scientist that would just increase my
desire to uh to re to belay that order
and and to release it and I think that's
true of of our our community in general
all right thank you so much I am going
to go on to our third set of questions
um is has NASA been tracking Earth's
atmosphere or are we also studying
bodies of water for for UAP and I think
that's a Dan question Vanessa or
yep here's the oceanographer
um uh so you know my understanding is
this is a completely independent study
to assess
you know what assets what data
um what science What observations
platforms NASA has to
potentially help evaluate and understand
uh UAP right we have um well NASA has an
earth science Division and many
scientists at many centers and many
academics and other partners out there
that study the Earth as a system we do
this from the unique vantage point of
space and the atmosphere is part of that
um so uh I think Dr Kirkpatrick stated
this morning that to his knowledge and I
think to ours there there isn't anything
that's been reported below the ocean
surface
um you know and so I think
part of what we've been talking about
all day is you know what assets are out
there to actually
begin to
um
identify data that could be useful in
explaining any of these reports if and
should they come in so I think that's
probably it unless there's something
else to add
all right then thank you
moving on to our fourth
General bucket of questions uh what are
you doing to solve the stigmatization
surrounding the study of UAP
I can take that one
and say your name if you wouldn't mind
first Carl and toner FAA
um I think the fact that NASA has called
us together here as a panel to look into
this that NASA is hosting a public
meeting that we've heard right it
clearly stated we're here to be
transparent I think that's the first
step in trying to really normalize the
study of uaps and I you know we talked a
little bit earlier about the reporting
about how to make it credible and we
talked also about UAP in one of the
earlier talks this morning of of the
definition of the a whether it was Ariel
or anomalous as the legislation now is
and really the distinction Beyond UFOs
right when we're looking at uaps here
we're Beyond just airplanes we're
looking at all types of anomalous
phenomena
um and so that's just a more inclusive
term there
still my goal
um just wanted to emphasize what uh
Carlin said which is so accurate I
really consider it quite amazing that
we're here having this discussion as the
leadership serves great kudos for this
and Beyond I think a recommendation that
I'd like to make is that NASA
participate in symposia in panels
sponsor research when you have the NASA
logo on that sponsored research on the
discussion it really helps normalize and
push back against the stigma I think
NASA can leverage this excellent
reputation both domestically and abroad
to help push back on that stigma I think
it's important to do so not just for
Science and Discovery but for National
Security that we've all seen what's
occurred with balloons from rival
Nations we don't want this stigma to be
a vulnerability that rival Nations can
take advantage of
yes Dan yeah thanks Karen just a few
additional points um from the agency
perspective we are of course taking a
set of actions to effectively normalize
the study of uaps and that involves
collaborating across the government
encouraging an open dialogue and
promoting rigorous scientific inquiry
let me turn to each of those interns so
in terms of promoting a rigorous
scientific inquiry the primary way we're
doing this is by being truly rigorous
and employing an evidence-based
methodology in everything that we do
that is characteristic of scientific
research it's no accident that the
people up on this stage are true experts
in their reflex respective Fields okay
so that is in turn going to help us to
legitimize UAP studies encouraging open
dialogue so by holding public meetings
such as this one and having open
conversations about findings then we're
helping to normalize discussions again
and that that really goes arm and arm
with our commitment to openness and
transparency with the public and then
finally in terms of collaborating across
the government we're working very
closely with other government agencies
not least Sean's office Aero to broaden
the scope and the depth of our study and
I honestly believe that this Collective
interagency approach will lend
credibility to the study of uaps and
it's going to demonstrate the
seriousness with which we're approaching
this issue thanks well that segues very
nicely into what our next set of
questions are which is uh who we are
working with so the question is who else
is NASA currently working with or do we
want to work with to study UAP and is
NASA working with International partners
um as
the questions tasked to this panel so
kindly asked us both in what other
government agencies are collecting data
what data is available NASA is
partnering with them in in many ways as
well as National NASA has a wide
commercial Outreach
and Partnerships with understanding what
data is available
as well as National NASA's founded on on
well not founded but it the
core principles of of NASA are with
International Partners so the
information that our partners are
gathering is is typically available to
NASA as well so
yes on all accounts and I may just
emphasize and add that NASA is singular
I believe among government agencies and
it's International Outreach again not to
keep talking about the Artemis Accords
but you see countries like Saudi Arabia
that we may not have a great
relationship with as Government right
now we have Saudi Arabia and Israel in
the Accords family so that NASA is
unique in its scope and ability to reach
out I also think that we're entering a
new era of commercial space
transportation that is going from low
earth orbit out to Sis lunar's space and
that is going to be the purview of the
Department of Commerce which is taking
over Space Traffic management so I think
it's very important that NASA work with
and support Commerce as we go through
that transition Department defense is
currently responsible for that and I
think that will help us not only to
identify potential uaps but to assist in
preventing contention congestion and
eventually conflict and I also want to
note in terms of space debris debris and
wherever right now I believe represents
an existential threat to our very
society that we are getting very close
to an event that could cause real
problems for our ability to access
satellites and that's why I think
there's great ancillary benefits to the
conversation we're having today that is
we increase our capability to monitor
orbit for uaps that data could also be
very relevant as we look at nearest
objects and other threats and again it's
just end on near Earth objects apothesis
for example an asteroid is going to come
so close to Earth it will be below
geosynchronous satellites so any effort
to begin to catalog and do better in
terms of understanding that environment
is going to be terrific and I hope NASA
works with Commerce and international
agencies on Apophis and other missions
I think Federica had something to say
yeah I just wanted to add that you know
a lot of the things that we think we
might recommend in terms of platforms to
collect data that would be useful to
study uavs you know we recommend the
multi-platform and multi-site that would
also mean likely ground-based as well as
space-based facilities
um and this is being done already in
astrophysics codes Irving the sky from
the ground and from space with different
methodologies and different different
instruments to get a more comprehensive
picture of what's normal and then the
type of phenomenals and um about every
10 years the scientific the astrophysics
Community anyways but many other
branches convene a panel of experts to
see what things can be done to advance
um the the field in the next decade it's
called the decada survey for us and one
of the recommendations this year was
explicitly for agencies that do
astrophysics to work together so NSF doe
and NASA to work to together share data
share facilities and instruments so I
think this is
um you know there's a lot of fields
would benefit from this including the
UAP studies
oh
absolutely Carl and toner I I'd like to
put an exclamation point on how well
NASA is collaborating across the
government I can I'm from the FAA and I
can personally attest that you know FAA
and NASA have a robust uh engagement in
transferring Research into practice in
the ATM system I think on the commercial
space side we work well with NASA and
and all of our agencies are in the whole
of government approach supporting Arrow
specifically on the uip topic and and
you know it really comes down to good
government and how we deliver because we
can each work our own mission space but
to cover the whole Space we need to
collaborate together
and Dan do you put an exclamation point
on Carlin's exclamation point uh
so I think it's important to say that
you know we really do have a good
relationship with the auto main anomaly
resolution office error Sean's office
um and it's previous or predecessor
organization the UAP task force and we
have really benefited from very fruitful
collaborations among those various
entities and quite frankly as as a
taxpayer one should expect nothing less
than the government to be working
effectively across different units
together it's only right
um
that being said it's also important to
acknowledge what NASA's perspective is
in this study and to acknowledge that
you know the the Department of Defense
the intelligence Community have have
massively different equities about the
study of UAP and they have different
interests ours is a purely scientific
one so you know we collaborate we
consult it's a very good relationship
and I agree wholeheartedly with Carolyn
that a whole of government approach is
absolutely the right one to take
great thank you I will move on to our
sixth bucket of questions uh which we
had many on this topic is there evidence
that UAP were created from non-human
intelligence
yes please
I will take this one
um first and foremost We Are Scientists
and we follow the scientific process and
I hope that the Gathering here today
showed a little bit of a glimpse on how
the scientific process works
um it's not a question that you can
answer very quickly with yes or no
um and we followed the data right so
um as scientists we follow the data we
formulate hypotheses we test theories we
follow the scientific process the role
of this panel has been to create a road
map and a framework for how all
scientists that are interested in this
phenomenon can further study can further
collect data can further formulate
experiments or again hypotheses can test
different methods maybe even innovate on
the methodology side of things come up
with new methods for how we can do
basically science but not just any kind
of science but the science of Discovery
and exploration which is basically in
the spirit of NASA so just like Carl
Sagan I was saying extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence
we cannot make that kind of
extraordinary claims at all for any kind
of big subjects in science whether it's
uaps whether it's biosignatures whether
it's techno signatures this question of
whether we are alone in the universe is
probably one of the largest questions
that we've had in our history of Science
in our history of humanity and it's not
one that we can take lightly and that's
why we need so many scientists and
multi-disciplinary and interdisciplinary
teams to work together and many
organizations
so it's a process it's a roadmap and we
work collectively on this and we hope
that within our lifetime we will be able
to answer this big question of whether
we are alone or not and also to better
characterize this phenomenon which is
uaps
I want to sort of supplement that
excellent answer by noting that we have
not seen the extraordinary evidence
right that I mean in a sense to give you
know to make the claim that we see
something that is evidence of
you know uh non-human intelligence it
would be or would require extraordinary
evidence
and we have not seen that I think that's
important to make clear
all right then I will move on to our
seventh set of questions we received
many questions about the budget that is
being uh dedicated to this uh how large
of a budget will NASA allocate how large
of a budget is NASA allocating and how
large of a budget will NASA allocate
towards this the study of UAP it's Dan
yeah that's a down question so there are
two separate questions in there which is
what is the budget for this group this
team and what is the budget going
forward I think now the budget for this
independent study team is is very
consistent with any other of our
external review groups that we bring
into the science Mission director on an
annual basis so you know we have maybe
100 200 such groups entirely consistent
with that
also important to say going forward now
that NASA has not established a program
relative to UAP
and as a result there's no Associated
programmatic funding but this is how
NASA Works Federal budgeting is is a
complex uh journey of course and the way
NASA particularly NASA science likes to
work is we anticipate and weight
recommendations from independent groups
such as this one and we need to wait on
Final recommendations and and then we'll
make an assessment so too early to say
but of course that's all couched in the
fact that Federal budgeting is a very
complex process and we will always
follow the law
all right we're making good time
we have one more question that that
accomplished many of the ones we got
which is has NASA encountered any aliens
or extraterrestrial life what happens if
the public comes across extraterrestrial
life what would NASA do if
extraterrestrial life was discovered
what would NASA study or do if
extraterrestrial life was discussed now
I I think it's worth making a
distinction that they're when we talk
about extraterrestrial life we do have a
study within NASA of astrobiology which
is not intelligent life necessarily and
so I invite you as you answer this
question to make clear the distinctions
as you are talking
um uh in terms of
uaps as well as any astrobiology work
that we do
I would start by saying one of NASA's
big questions is is there life out there
right and a lot of what NASA is doing
in its exploration of the solar system
and beyond is focused on
searching for life in any form
extraterrestrial way
I think one of the things we have
learned
in the past 20 years is planets are
common we knew of course about the
planets in our solar system but we now
know there are lots of planets out there
so there are lots of potential
environments for life
and I think one of the most fascinating
questions is
do any of those planets host life
and that's uh something that NASA is
trying to address in a host of different
ways
whether it's probes that are landing on
planets or designing missions that will
look for signatures of life around other
planets so
the search for life is a really
important theme
we haven't found life beyond Earth yet
right I mean let's be clear about this
we haven't found it yet
but we're looking and we're looking for
it in lots of different ways and you
know
David was discussing techno signatures
as one way that we can look both within
our solar system and beyond and there's
so there's a lot a lot of different
elements I think of this potential
search
and
um you know just to go back to something
sort of those phrase in an earlier
question you know isn't NASA hiding
anything about this
no this is actually what you know
answering this question is one of the
things that NASA is an agency is is
excited about it's what's something that
lots of scientists working with NASA are
excited about is is this question of uh
is there life out there you know and I
think one of the things that
makes this question of are we alone such
a central question
not just to the scientific Community
it's a central question I think for the
public
I suspect there are more people watching
this than the typical episode of NASA TV
right and this is something where we
will have me you know media coming to
the press conference
because these questions touch on
something that I think is really a deep
question for Humanity
is are we alone in the universe
yeah just a kind of echo what David said
a bit I mean obviously this is something
uh we think a lot about in astrobiology
what you know what if we succeed
um and uh you know we are very driven uh
to try to find uh real evidence of
extraterrestrial life and
um we would be highly driven to share
that if we found it because everyone
wants to show that they've been able to
succeed in what they're trying to do and
and you know one perhaps illustrative
example is to think about what happened
when we came across when NASA thought
maybe they had discovered
extraterrestrial life and and
um a big event actually in the history
of astrobiology was in in the 1990s when
some scientists had thought that they
discovered fossils in a meteorite that
came from Mars
um and
what happens is you don't announce it
immediately you make sure that you try
to make sure you're right because you
don't also don't want to have false
alarms and announce something where and
then you go oops sorry we were wrong
that was a mistaken analysis but what
happened was when the when
the scientists were sure they were right
then
um there was a big
um in fact presidential press conference
with President Clinton and NASA and it
was a big Public Announcement and
um that's what would happen if we
discovered something we would try to
make sure we were right and then we
would very proudly and loudly let the
public know about it
thanks we've just one minute left so
I'll let you finish up yeah thank you um
the only thing I wanted to add I
wouldn't at all liken it to um alien or
extraterrestrial life but in
astrobiology and exobiology you know
there is the exploration of our planet
as an analog for what might be found
on other worlds
um you know and what what is extreme
cold what is extreme heat
um a volcano A black smoker at the
bottom of the ocean what lives there and
how's that even possible and things we
still discover throughout our ocean
might look alien to a lot of people
right
um and we keep discovering new species
of different things whether they be
microbes or algae or you know
charismatic megafauna whatever they are
um but there are synergies I know there
was an initiative years ago at Nasa
called oceans across the solar system
and the idea was could our own Earth's
ocean be used in the life within it as
an analog for what might be discovered
elsewhere so I think that's an example
of a potential Synergy of
interdisciplinary science research
observations Etc collection of data and
information gathering that could be
useful in the future
thank you all so much I will hand it
back to David spurgle your chair
[Applause]
so let me also just answer the one other
piece of that question was what do you
do if you see something surprising where
do you report
and this is something where just to come
back to something I mentioned my opening
remarks the aaro is the our lead Agency
for uaps
and while we've talked about orig you
know life in this context
most uaps
I think when one looks at the data in
more detail are going to turn out to be
phenomenal we understand we saw this
with some of the balloons or or
commercial Jets we saw those examples
some uaps and we saw this with the
Chinese balloon that flew over is
something an issue sometimes of National
Security
so we actually do want to encourage
people
just from that angle
to report it
so you know uh
since uh just before it will transition
to summary but that's what it is on that
question that you know to keep in mind
that
um you know the aaros role is to be the
prime source for understanding those
things
and what our charge is is to think about
what's NASA's role
and I think NASA you know and this is
something you know we'll con I want to
now go back to discussion we didn't have
that much time for it just to to come
back to you know what we each you know
what we see as NASA's role
in this
um I think one world piece we've talked
about is
be uh NASA can help remove the stigma
NASA can draw more of the scientific
community in
and I think what NASA could help do is
provide standards of high data quality
I think one of the things that many of
us who've come you know not looked at
this before I certainly put myself in
this group
it was struck by the limited nature of
the data that many events had uh
insufficient data
and that in order to get a better
understanding we will need to have you
know high quality data data where we
understand it's provenance
data from multiple sensors
and I think one of the things that uh
you know even from the same sensor as we
saw
you know in Josh's analysis you know
also an event Sean showed us when you
can observe event over time
and get velocity information that gives
you a lot of additional information so
we're going to want things with high
frame rate
we're going to want things from multiple
perspectives
um and uh you know so I I think those
are all going to be pieces of things
that we want to think about
um
I think this is an opportunity for
citizen science
I think if
we can come up with recommendations in
our roadmap that point to ways in which
we could collect it people can collect
data I remain a big fan of these things
they do take over our lives too much but
they are
fabulous data collectors of and I don't
know there's something like three four
billion of them that are on the planet
and
NASA I think has the
Prestige and visibility to develop
an app or work with companies to develop
apps that could collect data in a
uniform and centralized way
um that I think will you know most the
stuff that's collected is going to turn
out to be commercial planes balloons uh
when you have multiple cameras you can
eliminate some of the optical
limitations of ghosting and those
effects
um some of them will almost certainly be
novel physical phenomena
right I think it is we have learned a
lot about our planet and how the
universe works there's a lot we don't
know
right I think yeah you know as
as scientists what is the most exciting
thing
is the surprises
and I think that there are things that
continue to surprise us about our own
Planet there's phenomenon in our
atmosphere in the atmosphere that we
probably haven't seen yet or perhaps
we've seen and not
noticed yet right in this I I think a a
long history in science when you look
back and you realize
that this in Discovery had a
pre-discovery so people had seen
something before and we're missing it
and
those pre-discoveries were not of note
often because
we had biases against seeing it but
often because there was limitations in
data quality
and uh
you know one of the things I was taught
is uh when you have a question you don't
know how to answer you start by getting
better data
and uh you know I
were coming you know I get to do the
summary and as the chair I get to
you know summarize a conclusion and
um
we need better data would be my my
takeaway
and we need more uniform data
and since I'm so proud of my Haystack
we need to be able to understand what's
in the haystack and it's
a lot more complicated than a haystack
in a sense right as you know it's got
commercial planes it's got you know
drones and you know I think the number
of drones out there is large and growing
and will be a continual source of
confusion
um
we were charged to think about air
safety you know understanding and
characterizing seeing what's going on
with drones is also I think going to be
an important air safety issue
um so we'll need to uh
you know to understand the unknown or
start to study the unknown another
important piece is always going to be
characterizing the known
really well
and um you know this is the part I think
of a lot of science that seems dry and
boring
but it's calibration and understanding
the events you expect to see
you know in thinking about this area one
of the groups of people that people talk
to are particle physicists doing
experiments at CERN
where they go through the effort of
finding extremely rare events to find
new particles
and in order to do that you need to
understand the standard predictions well
so I think another part of the whole
story
and I know this is something Aro is
working hard on in the context of
military it's like you've got to
characterize what you the known Things
Are you know when you've got that
F-35 flying past a balloon what does it
see what does it see at Sunset what does
it see in odd observing angles and that
characterizing the normal
is an essential thing to do to
understand what's out there
so let me
conclude the session by thanking the
panelists it's been a pleasure learning
from you
thanking our uh Sean and and our other
invited speakers and our our that we've
had we've had for uh some of our data
collection sessions we've learned a
tremendous amount from you
and also thank the public for their
engagement I think we were all impressed
by the the number and level and
sophistication of the questions people
sent in
we tried to address as many as them that
we could in the session
as you've heard NASA through
science.nasa.gov will provide there'll
be some additional answers provided
encourage you to go there
actually as a non-nasa employee I'll put
in a little ad for science.nasa.gov
NASA does amazing things
and we're learning amazing things about
the universe
and our planet and just encourage you to
go there
and uh
continue to learn and continue to
explore
so thank you all